Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und jetzt ist es
fast ein Jahr her, dass sich hier die letzte Sendung habe, veröffentlichen können. Die Gründe sind euch allen bekannt. Daran war leider wenig zu rütteln, denn nach wie vor bevorzuge ich hier alle meine Gesprächspartner
und Gesprächspartnerinnen natürlich persönlich zu treffen, um hier einfach den Themen wirklich auf den Grund gehen zu können
einfach über telefonische und Internetverbindungen so in der Form einfach nicht zu leisten ist. Und ja, von daher habe ich dann auch keine Mühen gescheut und mich hat dann gleich der erste Weg nach dieser langen Pause,
nach Madrid geführt, genauer an das Isak, das Astronomiezentrum der ESA.
Und ich freue mich sehr, meinen Gesprächspartner zu begrüßen, nämlich Günther Hasinger. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Pritlove und ich freue mich auch sehr bei Ihnen oder mit Ihnen zu sein.
Sehr schön. Ja, Sie sind ja der Leiter des des ESAC hier
also Madrid ist fast ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, nicht wahr? Also wir befinden uns hier so in so einer vorgelagerten Bergregion, sehr schön gelegen mit Blick auf nicht nur Antennen, sondern auch noch auf Schlösser,
Also muss sagen, im Bereich Konferenzraum, Optik ist das ganz weit vorne.
Danke, ja. Wir blicken hier auf einen islamisches ehemaliges Castell, also ein eine Burg
benutzt wurde, um sozusagen die islamischen, den islamischen Teil Spaniens zu verteidigen gegen
den christlichen Wiedereroberungsfeldzug. Und der wurde dann auch im Dreißiger Jahren mit dem Franco Krieg auch zerstört. Also es ist sehr historischer Platz hier.
Auf jeden Fall, auch was die Raumfahrt betrifft, weil die, die hier standen, die waren sozusagen die Grundlage für diesen Standort. Das war ja nicht von Anfang an ein Standort der ESA, richtig?
Doch die Antennen wurden sozusagen spezifisch für einige ESA-Missionen hier aufgebaut, also das hieß früher Wilsbar, das war praktisch die Villa Franka, Spanien Antenne. das gab das Servatory Iso, da wurde die erste Antenne dafür gebaut,
Wurde die Zweite gebaut und sukzessive, je mehr,
Mission hier betrieben wurden, desto größer wurde die Anlage und dann zweitausendsieben, glaube ich, wurde es dann in einen dieser Standort umgewandelt.
Zum Esack mache ich sicherlich in einer anderen Sendung dann nochmal mehr. Heute soll's gehen, um das James Web,
Teleskop, das kam hier schon mal zur Sprache, als der Schwerpunkt auf dem Habbelteleskop lag vor einigen Sendungen, aber jetzt nach vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren steht dann
wirklich mal der Launch dieses neuartigen Weltraumteleskops an
Darüber wollen wir sprechen, aber wie's hier so gute Sitte ist, würde ich natürlich gerne erst mal mit ihnen einsteigen und mal hinterfragen,
Ja, wie wie die Wissenschaft denn so in ihr Leben getreten ist. Sind sie auch so die Kategorie schon als kleines Kind in die Sterne geschaut oder.
Nein, ich ich war, nein, ich war von Anfang an fasziniert von technischen Dingen. Ich habe Kosmos Baukästen und Merlin, Eisenbahn und Merkel im Kästen, also ich war eigentlich immer ein Bastler.
Aber eigentlich meine Eltern waren beide Ärzte, also eigentlich hatte ich für ursprünglich vor Medizin zu studieren.
in der Zeit, wo ich mich hätte entscheiden müssen für ein Studium waren wir mitten in Studioaufnahmen. Ich hatte nämlich eine Band, eine der,
besseren Bands Münchens und wir haben Plattenaufnahmen gemacht. Irgendwann hat mich meine Mutter angerufen und hat gesagt, wenn du dich jetzt nicht sofort bei der Uni einschreibst, dann verliere ich mein Kindergeld und dann bin ich hingegangen und habe mich,
eingeschrieben. Und dann, wenn man Physik studiert, macht man natürlich auch Praktika. Da habe ich also alle möglichen interessanten Versuche gemacht. Aber das schönste Prakt
war eines, wo ich dann den ganzen Sommer über in der Universitätssternwarte in München Bogenhausen einen Stern anschauen musste, Nachtzimmer.
Dann ist irgendwann mal mitten während meines Praktikums eine Nova explodiert. Nova, Zykleni, neunzehnhundertachtundsiebzig,
dann hat mich mein Betreuer aus dem Urlaub angerufen, hat gesagt, dein Thema hat sich geändert, du musst jetzt diese Nova beobachten. Dann habe ich also Nacht für Nachtspektren dieser Nova aufgenommen. Die wurde natürlich immer schwächer, immer schwächer
hat sie, habe ich sie irgendwann mir im Teleskop nicht mehr gesehen, dann habe ich ein Hilfsfernrohr dazu eingebaut, also ich konnte auf die ganzen Anlagen der Sternwarte zugreifen,
Und ich habe die beobachtet, noch weit über mein Praktikum hinaus, bis dann irgendwann das Oktoberfest in München losgegangen ist und der Himmel so hell geworden ist, dass man nix mehr gesehen hat.
Aber das war mein Einstieg in die Astronomi.
Mhm. Okay, das ist ja schon ein richtiger, ich meine, das ist ja ein Fingerzeichen des Himmels im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ja, genau. Und dann habe ich eine Vorlesung bei Herrn Trümper gehört, meinem Doktor Vater. und der hat mich dann mehr oder weniger für die für die Röntgenastronomie fasziniert und nie wieder losgelassen.
Ja und ich stelle gerade fest, ich hatte ja auch hier schon ein Gespräch mit Herrn Trümper über sein Rosat Projekt, mit dem er sehr bekannt geworden ist und das ist in der Tat fast auf den Tag genau.
Zwei Tage vorbei zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme vor zehn Jahren gewesen.
Ist ja toll.
Genau, wo es halt viel um Röntgenastronomie ging und die Bedeutung der Röntgenastronomie natürlich auch die Bedeutung des Rosa Satelliten, der damals ja eine ganze Menge losgetreten hat. Ja und das ist dann quasi auch ihr Thema geworden. Genau. Mhm.
Und ich habe mit Rosa sehr viel also schon in der Vorbereitung. Ich hatte an den,
Spiegeln gearbeitet und hab mit dazu beigetragen, dass Rosa die glatteste Oberfläche der Welt wurde, die ins Guinessbuch der Rekorde eingegangen,
ist. Und ich habe auch im Lagerregelungssystem von aktiv mitgemischt und habe den dann hinterher auch retten können als einer der oder zwei von den Kreiseln kaputtgegangen sind. Also ich habe einen Großteil meiner Karriere mit Rosat gemacht.
Mit in den tiefen Weltraum geblickt und die ganzen schwarzen Löcher am Himmel gefunden,
Bei manchen Leuten hängen ja, da hängt der Himmel voller Geigen, bei mir hängt der voller schwarzer Löcher. Und das ist das Thema, was ich immer noch sehr, sehr stark verfolge.
Ja. Denn dieser Spiegel von Rosat war ja damals eine ja nicht nur eine Meisterleistung, sondern auch ein totales Novum durch diese spezielle Glattheit. Und ich meine, mich zu erinnern, dass es auch so ein bisschen die Vorlage war für die Gleitsichtbrille, nicht wahr?
Richtig, ja.
Bevor vorher mussten die Optiker, wenn sie schleifen, immer Sphärische Flächen schleifen, also sie konnten sie extrem präzise, aber eben nur sphärisch
brauchte aber extrem aspherische Flächen, also paraboloide, hyperboluide
Da hat die Firma Zeis einen Computer kontrolliertes Polierkonzept entwickelt, womit man also jede beliebige Fläche schleifen konnte. Und das war der Anfang der Gleitsicht.
Und hat sicherlich auch Einfluss gehabt auf zukünftige Teleskope, die Spiegelschleiftechniken spielen daher eine große Rolle.
Ja, XMM Newton, was im im Orbit ist, Sandra und das sind alles im Prinzip Dinge, die auf der ursprünglichen Technologie passieren.
Wie ging's dann weiter für sie?
Ich bin dann habe also nachdem ich mit Rosat gearbeitet habe und meine wissenschaftlichen Sporen da verdient habe,
bin ich Professor am an der Uni Potsdam geworden und Direktor am Astrophysikalischen Institut Potsdam. Das war unmittelbar nach der Wende, wo man,
ehemalige Akademie-Institut sozusagen in ein westliches System überführen musste. Und da war ich acht Jahre in Potsdam.
Auf Einsteins Spuren, das war ganz toll. Und danach bin ich zurückberufen worden als Nachfolger meines Chefs, also Nachfolger von Herrn Trump,
ans Max Planke zu extrateristische Physik in Gaiching, wo ich dann Direktor wurde für die Astronomie und die Gamma Astronomie.
Es ging einige Zeit, also auch ungefähr sieben, acht Jahre und dann hat mich der Max Langpräsident überredet dazu,
diesen Pfosten zu verlassen und das der wissenschaftliche Direktor des Max-Planck-Instituts für Plasmaphysik zu werden. Das war zunächst mal natürlich nicht direkt in meiner Sichtlinie, weil das nicht Astrophysik ist, aber,
es hat doch sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten, also auch Röntgen, heiße Plasman und ich konnte eben auch weiterhin meine erste Physik weitermachen, aber letztendlich ging's darum,
Fusionsforschung in Deutschland sozusagen salonfähig zu erhalten. Also da gab's sehr starke politische zurücke dagegen
und das ist mir gelungen. Wir haben dann einen Besuch von der Bundeskanzlerin Merkel in unserem Fusionsreaktor in Greifswald bekommen, wo sie sich sehr stark für die Forschung ausgesprochen hatten. Das war also ein sehr positives Element.
Kurz darauf ist Fukushima explodiert und Deutschland ist aus der gesamten Atomenergie ausgestiegen, aber nicht aus der Fusionsforschung. Es.
Weil das ja was anderes ist, ja.
Genau. Und ich bin dann aber, ich habe das quasi als Sprungbrett benutzt,
einen lang gehegten Traum von mir zu erfüllen, nämlich nach Hawaii zu gehen. Ich bin dann Direktor der Sternwarte in Hawaii geworden, also das ähm
Astronomen, Astronomieinstituts der Universität von Hawaii, was praktisch der Gastgeber für alle diese großen Teleskope war
auf den beiden großen Bergen und,
und hab da dann auch also gekämpft für das zukünftige Großteleskopie im T und auch für das Penstar Steve Gruppen.
Ungefähr acht Jahre meines Lebens in Hawaii verbracht. Das war wunderschön. bin aber.
Sind schon Experte für besondere Ausblicke. Also in Potsdam ist es ja auch recht malerisch, also.
Stimmt, ja. Aber da gab's auch eben wieder Dränge zurück nach Europa zu gehen. Wir haben ein Enkelkind bekommen, was in Berlin immer gerufen hat. Opa, Oma, komm, komm und irgendwie
haben wir dann beschlossen zurück nach Europa zu gehen und der Job hier,
in Madrid und auch in Norweg. Ich habe ja einen Teil meiner Mitarbeiter gearbeitet, auch in Holland, bei Estic,
das war sozusagen einer meiner Traumjobs, es ist wirklich fantastisch hier.
Hm? Ja, denn hier geht's viel um Astronomie und hier der Madrider Standort des ist ja so quasi der.
Der Arm der Isar, der sich halt vor allem um die Wissenschaft, die wissenschaftliche Auswertung der Beobachtung des Weltalls kümmert. Während ja andere Standorte
wie man das hier schon oft mitbekommen hat, eben auch andere Schwerpunkte hat. Darmstadt mit der Missionskontrolle Forschung in Italien, die zentrale in Paris und eben
dass mit den ganzen Satelliten baut, Überprüfung in in Holland, so ist das ja ganz gut verteilt. Ähm.
Machen sie jetzt wie lange schon hier? Also sind sie jetzt.
Ich bin jetzt dreieinhalb Jahren hier.
Also schon eingearbeitet.
Ja. Und werden noch ungefähr eineinhalb Jahre hier bleiben und.
Man denn dann noch zur Forschung? Also ist denn das.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt schon, wenn man sich das als Priorität setzt und Mühe gibt, wir haben gerade vor drei Tagen ein neues Paper eingereicht, wo wir,
darstellen, ob möglicherweise die dunkle Innen, na tschuldigung, die dunkle Materie aus primadialen, schwarzen Löchern besteht. Das ist im Moment mein Forschungsthema.
Und ich habe selber auch ein, ein Einzel-Single, Allser-Paper vor einem Jahr eingereicht, da habe ich die.
Benutzt, um sozusagen, also im im Lockdown mich wirklich mal auf ein völlig neues Thema zu konzentrieren. Es ist sehr spannend, also wenn das stimmt, dann würde das den,
20, 30 Jahre physikalische Entwicklung auf den Kopf stellen.
Und die ganzen Partikel Beschleuniger frustriert abmarschieren, weil's dann doch kein neues äh.
Partikelteilchen gibt, was irgendwie die dunkle Materie repräsentieren kann. Ja, das ist ja ein interessantes Feld. Da kommen wir sicherlich dann auch gleich nochmal drauf, denn
Beim James Web Teleskop geht's ja nun wirklich auch genau dadrum, nämlich.
Ins All zu schauen, so weit wie man bisher noch nie geschaut hat. Hab.
Hat ja hervorragende Bilder geliefert und eine fast nicht,
abzählbare Zahl an Beobachtung, Studien produziert. Ich glaube ist das richtig sehe, wurde zwar Habel jüngst von Gaya schon wieder überholt was was diesen Auto,
betrifft, aber das spielt in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch nochmal eine in einer ganz anderen Liga, wenn man einfach mal alles zählt.
Darüber habe ich ja hier mit Stefan Jordan auch schon gesprochen über den neuen Geier, Katalog und da ist ja dann auch in in der nächsten Zeit, ich glaube, nächstes Jahr mit dem vollen Katalog auch noch einiges zu erwarten.
Da gibt's eine ganz interessante Story. also tatsächlich ist es so, Hubble,
publiziert er im Moment ungefähr 1tausend Papers pro Jahr, also jeden Tag drei Papers,
Und das ist für sich genommen schon fantastisch und habe ist ja schon seit 30 Jahren unterwegs, also wenn sie alle Papers von Huble auf integrieren, dann ist das, glaube ich, uneinholbar. Geier fliegt seit ungefähr ein bisschen mehr als fünf Jahren und,
publiziert im Moment 60Prozent mehr Papers pro Jahr als Hable, also 1600. und das ist schon fantastisch, wenn man sich überlegt, dass das unser Bild von der Astronomie praktisch von dem,
den Füßen auf den Kopf stellt im Moment. Und,
integriert ist natürlich Geier auf jeden Fall noch weit hinter aber es gab jetzt vor kurzem auf Twitter gerade eine Abstimmung welches das bessere Teleskop sei, Habbel oder gar ja,
und das ist total knapp ausgegangen, also fifty-fifty sozusagen und also beide sind absolute Spitzen äh
Teleskope und kann man eigentlich fast nicht miteinander vergleichen, aber dass wir diesen Luxus haben, sowohl haben als auch Geier so viel Outfit zu sehen, das ist schon.
Herr Geier ist vor allem Futter für die Wissenschaftler und Hubble auch, aber.
Eye Candy, ja.
Ich denke, Habel hat einfach auch sehr viel dazu beigetragen, die Faszination der der Raumfahrt und die Faszination auch der Astronomie und Astrophysik
wieder ja neu zu beschreiben, neu neu neu ja neue Kanäle zu eröffnen, einfach einen Blick auf das All zu liefern, die Leute träumen lassen kann, weil
die Faszination der Mondlandung, hat sich jetzt dann doch auch ausreichend abgenutzt. sodass da eben ja neue Bereiche erforderlich sind.
Ja, dann kommen wir doch mal zum James Web Teleskop. Also, haben schon gesagt, zweitausendsieben hätte es eigentlich starten sollen
Warum so was dann so extrem verzögert werden kann? Die Gründe sind vielfältig, da kommen dann technische Probleme dazu. man muss das mit anderen Missionen abstimmen. Das muss alles getestet sein,
Pipapo, Pandemie kommt noch dazu, Kollision mit anderen Missionen. War, glaube ich, auch irgendwann mal ein Verschiebungsgrund und so addiert sich das dann alles auf,
Aber jetzt sieht es eben tatsächlich so aus, als ob's jetzt im November soweit sein würde.
Im Dezember. Wir haben im Moment am 18. Dezember ist der Starttermin.
Okay, im Dezember habe ich mich vertan. sprich das Teleskop ist bereits unterwegs, nehme ich an, ne, oder? Es ist.
Nee, das Rakete ist schon angekommen, das Teleskop ist noch nicht unterwegs.
Also wir nehmen hier Ende September auf, zwanzig einundzwanzig, muss man auch nochmal festhalten und ja, also Teleskop ist dann am auf Herz und Wiesen.
Interessant, sich zu überlegen, es muss ja durch den Panamakanal sozusagen von Kalifornien dann nach Französisch Guyana per Schiff transportiert werden. Also es wird wirklich verschifft und das ist natürlich spannend.
Kommt ja von der NASA. Das hatte ich jetzt gerade vertan. Ja und dann auf dem langen Weg nach um dort dann auf eine Ariane fünf,
ins All zu segeln. So, wie kam's denn nun dazu? Also, was,
hatten hier den Ausschlag gegeben.
Für dieses James Web Teleskop. Ich meine, ist klar, man will immer schon das nächste Teleskop planen, wenn auch klar ist, äh
das mit irgendwann eben auch nicht mehr weitergehen wird, solange das Ding jetzt auch schon läuft. Aber es ist ja kein direkter Ersatz für Hubble. wenn Habbel wegfällt, fällt
ein Auge weg, was man jetzt so nicht ersetzt bekommt. aber was sind so die.
Ziele gewesen oder was war sozusagen der Ansatz der wissenschaftlichen Gemeinschaft zu sagen, okay, genau so was brauchen wir jetzt.
Also als als Hable hat der hat er auch seine Anfangsschwierigkeiten gehabt mit den unscharfen Augen, die dann repariert wurden und erst dann,
diese fantastischen Bilder ergeben in den neunziger Jahren. Und es war aber damals auch schon so und es ist heute immer noch so,
Hubble liefert die scharfen Bilder, aber die wirkliche, sagen wir mal, physikalische Beurteilung und die tiefen Erkenntnisse sind dann auch,
Immer wieder von den großen, bodengebundenen Teleskopen gekommen. Das heißt also,
und zum Beispiel oder haben sehr sehr gut zusammen gearbeitet und es war von Anfang an klar, dass der Spiegel von für gewisse Dinge nicht groß genug ist, um wirklich in die tiefsten Tiefen zu schauen. Also.
Schon als Hampel flog und als alle so begeistert waren, haben die Leute eben,
wir brauchen so was wie ein acht Meter Teleskop, acht Meter, deswegen, weil damals die bodengebundenen Teleskope auch ungefähr acht Meter waren.
Das waren so die ersten Ideen, was würde es denn benötigen, um einen acht Meter Spiegel in den Weltraum zu bekommen. Und äh,
Das waren am Anfang viele Träume und letztendlich ähm
hat man festgestellt, okay, acht Meter wird's nicht, weil das kriegt man in keine Rakete rein. Das größte Teil, was man in eine heute existierende Rakete
reinbringen könnte, wäre sowas wie sechseinhalb Meter. und dann aber auch noch mit diesem Klapp
spiegeln die James Web hat. Und ich glaube aber, dass ähm
Tatsächlich des Keck-Teleskop da eine große Rolle gespielt hat, weil das Keck-Teleskop hat gezeigt, dass man eine große Fläche, zehn Meter Spiegel,
durch viele kleine Hexagons zusammensetzen kann und die Spiegel so kontrollieren kann, dass sie auch wirklich wie eine optische Fläche wirken. Also es gab in der in der Genese von James Web tatsächlich sehr, sehr enge Verbindungen.
Keck.
Also Cake ist das auf Hawaii.
Genau, das ist dieses die zweite Teleskop,
auf Hawaii, die im Moment immer noch die größten Teleskope der Welt sind oder fast, die aber auch die Basis für die zukünftige Generation von 30 und 40 Meter Teleskopen sind, also mit diesen,
unterteilten Spiegeln. Und ähm,
Naja und dann hat man sozusagen James Rap ein bisschen verglichen mit so einem Boden gebunden mit Teleskop, hat Kostenschätzungen gemacht, was da für notwendig wären. aber diese Kostenschätzungen waren am Anfang dramatisch unterschätzt. Ähm,
im Übrigen auch, wenn man sich rappel anschaut, tappel hat ja ursprünglich auch nur ungefähr eine Milliarde Dollar gekostet,
Wenn man dann alles da zusammenrechnet, was notwendig war, um in der heutigen Version zu haben, inklusive mehreren Shuttle-Starts und so weiter. Dann kam Habl auch auf zehn Milliarden etwa. Und da sind wir jetzt mit James Web auch, also ähm,
es es war am Anfang sozusagen ein bisschen Naivität, dass man es viel billiger machen kann, aber als man dann wirklich alles ausgewichst hat.
Und dann zusätzlich auch noch gemerkt hat, dass viele Dinge komplizierter sind als man sich selbst in der komplizierten Phase vorgestellt hat.
Sind wir halt jetzt auf zwölf Jahre Verzögerung und eine dramatische Kostenerhöhung gekommen,
Aber ich möchte es nochmal ins Verhältnis setzen, also James Web kostet ungefähr so viel wie Hubble uns gekostet hat und es ist jetzt auf also im Fall von Habl wird sich keiner,
Ob's das wert ist. Also das ist es einfach wert.
Das ist ja meistens so, mit diesen großen Missionen, also ich kenne eigentlich wenig Beispiele, vielleicht mal abgesehen von denen, die jetzt beim Staat Hobbs gegangen sind, wo man danach hätte feststellen können, es wäre jetzt viel zu teuer gewesen, weil der Nutzen,
Das haben wir ja hier auch schon oft gesprochen der Forschung, der ist halt nie unmittelbar, aber er ist auf jeden Fall mittelbar zu messen, ähm,
Prinzip findet ja die ein Großteil der Grundlagenforschung heutzutage. Eigentlich auf Basis von Weltraummissionen statt,
weil die Bedingungen, unter denen man irgendwie die Grundlagen noch ausbauen kann über das, was man heute weiß, so auf der Erde selten noch vorzufinden sind.
Das stimmt. Und es gibt einen Wert, den kann man gar nicht so wirklich in
Euros und Dollars berechnen, das ist der Wert der Inspiration von jungen Leuten überhaupt in diese technischen Felder einzutreten und Ingenieurs und wissenschaftliche Berufe zu ergreifen.
Die wir dringend brauchen, um in unserer Gesellschaft sozusagen weiterzuleben. Und das ist fast ein unschätzbarer Wert und da hat, glaube ich, unheimlich viel,
erzeugt.
Ja
Wir alle Missionen eigentlich, weil ich fand das mal eine schöne Feststellung. Ich weiß grad gar nicht mehr, aus welchem Gespräch das kam. Das ist ja jede Weltraummission ist immer ein Prototyp
einer einer zukünftigen Entwicklung. es wird nie etwas gebaut, was es schon mal gab. Und es muss für alle, für jede Mission immer irgendwas komplett Neues erfunden werden,
weil man das so nicht gelöst hat, da hätte man das schon gelöst, dann wär's ja sozusagen schon oben.
Und damit treibt man dann die Industrie zu Höchstleistungen an,
finanziert sie auch dafür sozusagen, was sie selbst von sich aus nie machen würden. Aber wir kennen so und so viele, also zick sogenanntes, wo dann eben Technologie aus der Weltraumforschung in die Bevölkerung eintritt.
Ich denke, es ist schon wichtig, sich das mal klarzumachen, wenn man jetzt sagt, so, ah ja, zehn Milliarden, ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt so zehn Milliarden Dollar nimmt und die aufm Scheiterhaufen verbrennt, sondern das fließt ja auch alles wieder in so eine Industrie rein und wird irgendwie,
hundertfach und tausendfach wieder in andere Produktivität umgesetzt.
Und jeder einzelne Dollar ist letztendlich auch ein Arbeitsplatz, also es von einem von zehn Milliarden redet, dann kann man da eben zehntausend Menschen damit über viele Jahre beschäftigen.
Aber kommen wir mal weg von der wirtschaftlichen Bedeutung hin zu der geplanten astronomischen Bedeutung. Also was soll James Web jetzt leisten? Wofür ist dieser Spiegel gedacht? Was soll beobachtet werden und warum?
Genau und vielleicht noch in der Historie zu zu bleiben. es ist ja nicht nur der Spiegel, sondern es sind auch die Instrumente, also die die Augen die und da war's ja so, bei Habbel,
Sind ja mehrere Generationen von Augen. Also erstmal die Brille und dann gab's kam's also mehrere Generationen von neuen Instrumenten, die da immer wieder hoch.
Also die Brille war, das habe ich ja gestartet wurde und durch einen Fehler in der Berechnung der Optik eigentlich unscharf gequal, genau.
Und daher jedes Instrument musste sozusagen eine zusätzliche Brille mitbekommen, damit Hampel dann scharf sehen kann.
Was dann aber auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Ja, genau. Und und bei James Web war's ganz klar, man muss sozusagen weg von der Erde, man kann das nicht mehr mithilfe von Astronauten reparieren oder austauschen
Das heißt, man muss die Suite von Instrumenten von Anfang an so intelligent gestalten, dass sie eigentlich also möglichst viel,
und das ist also genauso viel Energie praktisch gegangen in die Entwicklung von absolut top Instrumenten.
Hinterher nochmal drüber reden, aber das ist eigentlich auch ein ein Kriterium für James Web, dass es einfach sehr, sehr kräftig und mächtig ist.
Aber jetzt bezüglich der Wissenschaft ähm.
Gehen wir mal zurück zu wurde ja letztendlich eigentlich gebaut um die Hammelkonstante besser zu messen und das hat es auch sehr sehr gut gemacht. es war wesentlich dran beteiligt, die,
die dunkle Energie zu messen und es hat dafür dann auch den Nobelpreis bekommen. Also Hubble hat eigentlich in wundervoller Weise das erfüllt, wofür es eigentlich gebaut war.
Also die Havel Constante quasi ein Messwert für die Expansion des Universums.
Des Universums. Und und hatte also hat mitgezeigt, dass das dass das Universum sich morgen schneller ausdehnt als heute, also dass es gar nicht ein Urknall war, sondern dass die Urknall im Prinzip immer noch stattfindet und da gibt's also eine Kraft, die schiebt.
Also es ist eigentlich gar keine Konstante. Es ist eigentlich mehr eine.
Ja. Aber der der Punkt war was worauf ich hinaus wollte. Habl hat 20, dreißig, vierzig Mal mehr wissenschaftliche.
Ziele erfüllt, als nur die, für die es gebaut war, also diese ganzen Annähern, Announes, also die die unvorher Sehbahnen Dinge,
Ich möchte ein Beispiel bringen, wo ich selber auch ein bisschen eine Rolle gespielt habe, dass Penstars Teleskop hat zweitausendsieben,
gefunden. Das war, Entschuldigung, zweitausend7zehn. Das war als ich Direktor in Hawaii bin, also deswegen habe ich da auch ein kleines bisschen mit,
Bild ähm.
Ist ein interstellares Objekt, was also aus einem anderen Sternsystem kam und uns besucht hat. Und Hubble war entscheidend zu zeigen, dass sich dieses Objekt schneller von uns wegbewegt, als es reingekommen ist, ist also beschleunigt.
Und das war natürlich eine riesen Rätsel. Es gab einige Astronomen, die sagen, da müssten irgendwelche Raumfahrer drin sein. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein ein fremdes von einer fremden Zivilisation geschickt. Das Raum,
Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es wohl so, dass dieses Objekt ähm,
Ausgas, das besteht vermutlich aus Eis und das würden sie in die Nähe der Sonne kommt, dann wird es heiß, ähm
und schickt ein Stückchen seines Gases sozusagen in die andere Richtung und wird damit wegschleunigen. Aber das war etwas, also weder konnten wir uns träumen lassen, dass es interstellare Besucher gibt noch, dass wir,
Hilfe von Habl dann so viel lernen werden über über solche Geschichten. Das war also nicht Teil des ursprünglichen Wissenschaftsseiens Cases. Und das wollte ich eben auch sagen. Also James Web wird jetzt für einige sehr konkrete, insgesamt drei, vier,
Ziele gebaut,
Aber die Reichweite, wenn man mal so ein Fenster aufmacht und völlig neue Dinge sehen kann, ist halt gigantisch viel größer. Also da können wir heute noch gar nicht sagen, was die wirklichen Entdeckungen sein wird.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, man muss sich auf irgendwas festlegen. Also für irgendwas müssen ja diese Instrumente dann gebaut sein. Und wenn das Ziel ist, weiter zu schauen, als man bisher schauen konnte, musste man dann quasi auch die Frequenz wechseln, auf den man,
primär lauscht.
Genau, also zunächst mal ist es tatsächlich so, je weiter ein Objekt sich von uns wegbefindet, desto schneller bewegt sich's auch von uns weg, wegen der Ausdehnung des Raumes.
Und das bedeutet, dass das Licht dann zum Boden hin verschoben wird, die sogenannte Rotverschiebung
und das kann eben so weit gehen, dass es komplette Licht von einem Stern, also unsere Sonne hat ja ihr Hauptmaximum im sichtbaren Licht.
Das ist kein Zufall, sondern unsere Augen haben sich einfach dadrauf eingestellt. Aber dass dieses Licht komplett sozusagen ins Infrarote verschoben wird und dass man diesem Stern
mit sichtbarem Licht gar nicht sehen kann. Deswegen muss man also Infrarotaugen entwickeln.
Und wenn man dann mal Infrarotaugen hat, dann kann man aber alle möglichen anderen schönen Sachen machen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das mal gesehen haben. Das gibt so ähm,
in in Museen oder auch auf Wissenschaftsveranstaltungen manchmal so eine Vorstellung, wo ein Infrarot, ein Infrarotkamera, wo sie sich sozusagen in der Infrarotkamera sehen können
dann werden den Leuten zum Teil Mülltüten über den Kopf gestülpt und dann sieht man, dass man durch diese Mülltüte trotzdem den Menschen durchsehen kann.
Oder man kann eine Infrarotkamera einsetzen, um in einem Haus zum Beispiel zum Teil durch die Wände durchschauen zu können und so weiter. Also man sieht plötzlich ein völlig anderes Stück des Universums, was man vorher nicht gesehen hat.
Und das ist das, wo James Web eben so stark ist. Also einerseits
weil alles, was weit weg ist, rot ist, aber andererseits auch, wenn man dann mal im Roten beobachten kann, sieht man alle möglichen Phänomene, die man so nicht sieht.
So wie man jetzt in unserer Galaxis halt nicht weit kommt, wenn man jetzt auf die Galaxisscheibe blickt, weil alles so voll mit Staub ist, der halt das für unsichtbare Licht eben weitgehend blockiert, aber das Infrarotlicht wiederum stört sich da nicht groß.
Das ist die Basis, auf der ja mein Kollege Reinhard Genzel in Gaiching das schwarze Loch im Zentrum beobachtet, das kann er nur mit Infrarotaugen beobachten und so wird James Web natürlich auch viele Gebiete ein in viele Gebiete eindringen können, die wir bisher,
noch nicht sehen können. Aber lassen sie mich kurz zum Infrarot. Infrarot ist ja Wärmestrahlung letztendlich. Und wenn sie ähm,
Wärmestrahlung aus dem Kosmos empfangen wollen, da müssen sie im Prinzip auch dafür sorgen, dass ihr eigenes Teleskop nicht zu viel Wärmestrahlung hat, weil sonst ist es so, als wollte man Sterne bei Tag sehen, ne. Dann ist der Hintergrund,
stark. Und deswegen ist James Web das erste Teleskop, wo das gesamte Teleskop praktisch runtergekühlt wird auf Temperaturen und weit unter dem, also.
Unter dem Celsius.
Bei herrsche und blank war das ja auch der Fall.
da verherrschenden und Plank wurden die die Detektoren untergekühlt, aber nicht der Spiegel.
Und bei James Web ist es so, dass praktisch der ganze Spiegel kalt ist.
Und dort ist es deswegen braucht man eben dieses große Tennisplatz große Sonnenschirm diesen Sonnenschirm, der James Web sozusagen eine der meisten Sorgen bereitet hat, technologisch.
Also es muss ja eigentlich nicht gekühlt werden, sondern es muss verhindert werden, dass es sich erwärmt.
Ja, sagen wir mal so.
Ja da draußen ehm.
Wird vom Weltraum gekühlt und man muss dann verhindern, dass die Sonne und die Erde es sozusagen der Wärmestrahlung auf auswärts. Also das war ein eins der Konstruktionsnotwendigkeiten, dass man ein kaltes Teleskop haben möchte. Und in dem Moment, wo man das hat.
Es ist nicht nur so, dass die Fläche ist ja Fläche ist ja ungefähr zehnmal größer als äh,
sieht man es schon zehnmal mehr Licht, aber der Hintergrund ist auch zehn Mal niedriger als alles, was wir bisher hatten und deswegen ist in diesem Infrarotbereich James Web ungefähr hundert Mal empfindlicher als Habel.
Damit kommt man natürlich ähm,
sehr, sehr viel weiter. Und dann ist es so, dass durch den größeren Spiegel auch die Augen schärfer werden, also wenn man ein zwei Meter Spiegel wie Havel hat, dann hat man automatisch eine gewisse
limitierte Auflösung
sechseinhalb Meter, da ist das Bild etwa dreimal schärfer und dreimal schärfer in jeder Dimension sind schon auch wieder zehnmal weniger,
Hintergrund, was man aufsammelt, also auch das ist ein Faktor, der zusätzlich.
Also mit Hintergrund meinen sie das Rauschen. Ja. Was.
Ja oder die Wärmestrahlung, was sozusagen im Hintergrund aussieht,
Und dann gibt es jetzt eben, also wir haben vorher schon gesagt, man kann also nicht nur in weite Entfernungen schauen, weil alles rot ist, sondern man kann auch tief in die eingebette
Staub und Gas Wolken schauen. Und ein dritter Faktor ist bei der Planetenforschung. Da da ist es so, dass der Stern selber hat jetzt ein Maximum im sichtbaren Licht und wenn man ins Infrarote geht, dann,
Sternlicht schon nach unten. Der Planet hat aber sein Maximum im Thermalen Licht, also im infraroten Licht. Das heißt, das Verhältnis zwischen Planet und Stern,
wird besser wenn man ins Infrarot.
Ah ja, also man erhöht die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man Exo-Planeten direkt beobachten kann.
Erstens direkt beobachten kann, wenn man das Glück hat, dass sie weit genug weg sind. Da kommt dann noch der Faktor dazu, dass das Sternlicht selber eben auch schärfer ist durch das größere Teleskop. Also man kann näher an den Sternen hin beobachten. Aber selbst, wenn man nur,
zum Beispiel sogenannte Transitspektroskopie macht, also wenn man den Planet selber nicht sehen kann, aber wenn man den Schatten des Planeten vor seinem Stern sieht, ist halt dieser Schatten im Infraroten ausgeprägter als im sichtbaren Licht und man kann also genauer,
Licht nochmal aufspalten in seine Bestandteile und dann auch die Fingerabdrücke von zum Beispiel Molekülen oder chemischen Elementen in der Atmosphäre des Planeten sehen.
Das ist ja auch glaube ich etwas, was man sich immer wieder mal klarmachen muss. Ich habe neulich diesen schönen Ausspruch
gehört. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo es jetzt ja, aber war das am Ende, ich habe gerade einige meiner Raumzeitpodcast nachgehört. Kam das her, so diese Feststellung, dass eigentlich erst mit der.
Äh
die Astronomie zur Astrophysik wurde, dass man also nicht nur irgendwie einzelne Lichtpunkte sehen kann und so eine Sternenkarte und so eine Verortung beschreiben kann, sondern dass ja in zunehmenden Maße, eben diese Analyse der
drin, dieser dieser Lichtbestandteile, einfach auch die Grundlage dieses Forschens ist. Und ich glaube, das spielt ja auch bei Gyms Web eine besonders große Rolle.
Ja ich ich sage manchmal, es gibt doch den Spruch, ein Bild, sagt mehr als tausend Worte.
Und dann sage ich, ein Spektrum sagt mehr als tausend Bilder. Das heißt also, man kann im Prinzip, wenn man in der Lage ist, die,
Titelzusammensetzung des Lichtes in jedem einzelnen Bildpunkt aufzulösen, dann bekommt man ja ein dreidimensionalen Kubus von Informationen,
kann im Prinzip dann in jedem Bildpunkt auch noch sagen, was sind die physikalischen Zusammensätze, also die chemischen Zusammensetzungen, was sind die physikalischen Begebenheiten dort? Wie heiß ist es, wie dicht ist es, also
tatsächlich macht, die Gastronomie zur Astrophysik und das hat die Instrumentierung von James Web eben wirklich perfektioniert, also die diese beiden oder drei Spektographen, die dort fliegen, sind eben wirklich unheimlich ähm,
also man hat vier Instrumente, davon sind ist eins eine
Kamera, die wird die schönen Bilder machen, aber dann hat man drei Spektographen, die eigentlich im Wesentlichen die physikalischen Erkenntnisse liefern werden.
Mhm. Und inwiefern unterscheiden sich diese Spektographen, also warum braucht man 3 und zwei.
Ja, also das eine ist ein der das jetzt dieses kanadische Instrument, das ist ein mir also nah Infospektograph. Der ist aber ohne,
das heißt, er ist besonders gut geeignet,
helle Objekte zu spektoskopieren und der ist sehr gut einsetzbar für diese Exo-Planeten. da kann man also einzelne Objekte gut damit beobachten.
Und dann gibt es dem nah infrarotischen der von der ISA beigestellt wurde.
Der ist ein kleines technisches Wunderwerk für sich selber, weil der hat diese sogenannten Mikroelektronikspiegel, der kann also Spiegel hin und herschalten auf Mikro ähm
Bereich und kann sozusagen dann entscheiden, welcher Teil des des Bildes in den Spektographen hineingeht.
So wenn wir heute, also vom Boden aus sogenannte Multiobjektspektroskopie machen, wenn wir also in mit einem, mit einer Aufnahme hunderte von Spektren machen,
müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass jedes einzelne Sternchen sozusagen durch ein eigenes Loch durchgeht in den Spektographen, weil ansonsten ja das ganze Licht zusammen gemusschelt würde.
Und das macht man am am Boden zum Teil dadurch, dass man mit dem Laserlöcher bohrt in irgendwelche Aluminiumscheiben und diese Aluminiumscheibe dann vors Teleskop packt und genau sagt, welcher
jetzt beobachtet wird. Das können wir natürlich im Weltraum nicht machen
und dieses Mems, dieses Mikroelektronik, Maschinens das kann jetzt jedes einzelne,
Sozusagen ein- und ausschalten, also kann entscheiden, ob das Pixel sozusagen in den Fektografen geht oder nicht. Und damit hat man also eine extrem,
mächtige Beobachtungsmöglichkeit und kann also viele Galaxien gleichzeitig beobachten.
So im Prinzip so die Weiterentwicklung, was man so aus DLP-Projektoren kennt, ne, so ein kleiner Chip mit diesen Minisspiegeln, die quasi dann die richtige Farbe weiterleiten oder nicht.
Die gleiche Technologie wird jetzt im Weltraum eingesetzt, um zu entscheiden, welches Licht sozusagen in den Spektographen reinfällt. und hier bei den Projektoren ist es umgekehrt, da schickt man das Licht raus und entscheidet, welches Pixel sozusagen wo am Bildschirm erscheint.
Mhm. Also hat man nicht die Raumfahrt, die Technik auf der Erde inspiriert, sondern anders herum.
Oder auch beides, ja, weil das ist, glaube ich, ziemlich viel Geld in diese Entwicklung reingegangen und das ist ja auch im Hinblick auf James Web entwickelt worden und das selbe gilt natürlich auch für die Detektoren, für diese Infrarotdetektoren.
Die ja auch für viele andere Anwendungen notwendig sind, aber wenn man so viele Pixels hat, dann braucht man halt auch einen Detektor, der sehr mächtig ist. Und auch dort ist es so, dass dann durch die Entwicklung von James Rap auch die,
der einfach Unterdiktoren weitergetrieben worden ist.
Mhm. Und der dritte.
Der der dritte Spektograph ist ein Mitinfrarotspektrograph. Der ist also sozusagen für das Thermae also der Nahe Infrarot Graft, der geht so in dem Bereich zwei bis fünf Mikron. Das ist also,
ungefähr fünfmal,
sagen wir mal kälter als das das Sonnenlicht und der geht so in die Gegend von zehn bis zwanzig oder sogar fünfzig Müh, also zu noch kühleren. Ähm.
Und der ist sozusagen von der ähm.
von der technischen Ausrüstung ein bisschen einfacher als dem Niers Back. Dafür hat er aber diese spezielle Empfindlichkeit in einem anderen Wellenregenbereich.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt auch wirklich.
Extrem Fairness oder ein extrem schwaches auch beides Objekt schaut, was also sehr weit entfernt ist, dann würde man den rausholen und sagen, guck mal, oder man schaut sowieso immer mit allen hin, aber man kriegt unterschiedliche Ergebnisse.
Also ich ich habe selber ähm,
Freue mich, dass ich zusammen mit meiner ehemaligen Doktorantin ein Beobachtungsprojekt bekommen habe, wo wir also ungefähr 21 Stunden Beobachtungszeit von James Web bekommen, wo wir die aller frühsten schwarzen Löcher sehen wollen.
Sind welche, die wir im Röntgenlicht gesehen haben, also wo man sozusagen mit Sandra gesehen hat, da ist eine Rankenquelle.
Dann hat man aber im sichtbaren Licht mit Habeln nichts gesehen, absolut nichts. Und dann sieht man mit Spitze im Infraroten, dass dort Strahlung existiert und zum Teil sind, sieht man selbst.
Also mit den kälteren Wellning, also dort hat man Objekte,
Wenn man nicht weiß, worum es sich handelt, man weiß nur, dass sie Wärmestrahlung aussenden. Und je nachdem, was welcher Teil des Spektrums sozusagen schon bekannt ist, verwenden wir entweder,
Oder Miri für die beiden.
Also schwarze Löcher stehen ja so ein bisschen im Ruf unsichtbar zu sein, wie inwiefern kann man die denn dann doch nur doch noch sehen?
schwarze Löcher gehören frappierenderweise zu den leuchtkräftigsten Objekten im Universum.
Aber halt im Röntgenbereich.
Ja, wenn wenn's so ein schwarzes Loch mal richtig anfängt zu strahlen und zu fressen, dann kann es tausendmal heller sein als seine ganze Galaxie. Das nennt man dann Korsare. Und was wir dort sehen, ist wie immer,
Also auch zum Beispiel, wenn mein Kollege Reinhard Genzel dieses schwarze Loch im galaktischen Zentrum beobachtet, beobachtet er ja nicht, dass schwarze Loch selbst, sondern die Wirkung auf seine Umgebung, also er sieht die Sterne rumsausen
und er sieht eben im Prinzip auch das Gas, was dann.
Präventions.
Diese und das das Gas heizt sich dann auf, wie je näher es dem schwarzen Loch kommt
sendet quasi seinen letzten Hilfeschrei, bevor es reinstürzt in Form von Elektromagnetischer Strahlung aus und das kann man im Rankenlicht sehen, aber man kann sie auch im Infrarot, im Radio,
Also eigentlich ein über einen sehr breiten Wellenbereich strahlen die.
Wie weit sind diese schwarzen Löcher auf dieses abgesehen haben entfernt?
Ja und der der Punkt ist wenn wir sagen, wir können weiter rausschauen als jeder andere. Das hängt natürlich von der Helligkeit des Objektes ab,
Wenn sie einen Quaser haben, also ein schwarzes Loch, was tausendmal heller strahlt als seine eigene Galaxie, dann können sie den im Prinzip selbst mit schon bis ans Ende des Universums sehen
geht's im Prinzip gar nicht darum, dass wir nicht weit genug sehen können, sondern dass es diese Objekte damals einfach noch nicht gegeben,
hat. Und was wir jetzt mit James Web sehen können, sind eben welche,
die wesentlich schwächer sind als diese Korsare, vielleicht nicht tausendmal so hellstrahlen wie ihre eigene Galaxie, sondern nur einmal so hell. Und wir kennen,
bis Rotverschiebungen von etwa siebeneinhalb, also das wäre ungefähr 900 Millionen Jahre noch ein Urknall.
Wir kennen Galaxien,
Ist Rotverschiebung in der Gegend von zehn, das wäre ungefähr 700 Milliarden Millionen Jahre nach dem Urknall. Und wenn man diese Galaxien, deren Licht,
zerlegt in das Spektrum, dann stellt man fest, dass die Sterne, die in diesen Galaxienstrahlen schon viel früher entstanden sein müssen, vielleicht 200, 300 Millionen Jahre nach dem Rückknall und und James Rap könnte eben genau in diese
der sogenannten dunklen Zeiten blicken, wo das allererste Licht entstanden.
Also zweihundert, 300 Millionen Jahre nach dem Burgner ist echt früh, also das ist sozusagen wirklich mit so, dass die erste Aktivität, weil vorher brauchte ja das Universum erstmal eine Weile, um überhaupt erstmal durch.
Das das allerfrühste Licht ist ja sozusagen der Echo von dem Urknall, als das als das Universum noch ein heißer Feuerball war, so wie unsere Sonne.
Und dann langsam abgekühlt ist und dann plötzlich durchsichtig geworden ist. Das wurde, das ist damals, kann man sich vorstellen, wie so eine heiße Sonnenoberfläche, die aber jetzt durch die Rotverschiebung,
tausend Mal,
kälter geworden ist und das die strahlt ihr nicht im Radiobereich aus. Und da wissen wir ziemlich genau, dass dieses Licht 180.000 Jahre nach dem Urknall entstanden ist.
Zwischen 180.000 Jahre, also noch nicht mal eine Million und siebenhundert Millionen Jahren, wo heute das früheste Licht ähm,
Danach bekannt wurde. Da gibt's halt eine große Lücke und das da möchte James Web eindringen in diese Lücke.
Um rauszukriegen, was eigentlich überhaupt wirklich mal angefangen hat. Und natürlich auch welche Zusammensetzung.
Wann und wie, ja und und da spielt jetzt eben diese Frage wieder eine große Rolle. Also wenn es alles so ist, wie wir bisher gedacht haben, dass als erstes Sterne entstehen,
diese Sterne dann irgendwie explodieren und schwarze Löcher erzeugen und dass diese schwarzen Löcher dann wiederum Gas akkretieren müssen
Es dauert alles eine gewisse Zeit, bis man dann die ersten schwarzen Löcher hat.
Wenn es so ist, wie ich im Moment glaube, dass die schwarzen Löcher schon im Urknall entstanden sind, dann würde James Web das auch sehen können. Dann würde James Web schwarze Löcher sehen, viel weiter draußen.
Als wir bisher vermutet haben.
Also die Zielsetzung ist eigentlich relativ klar. Also vielleicht noch mal kurz zu dem ersten Instrument, die Kamera, also da geht's jetzt einfach um sichtbares Licht, um einfach zumindest halbwegs vergleichbare Bilder zu machen, aber ist ja trotzdem auch im Infrarot.
Ne, genau.
Sichtbar, sondern Infrarot.
Also sichtbar kann man's ja immer noch machen.
Und auch, ich meine, wenn man heute auf Bilder guckt von Supernov und anderen Sachen, ist es ja auch oft so, dass es so komponierte Bilder sind, die aus unterschiedlichen.
Künstlich zusammengesetzt.
Frequenzbereichen zusammengesetzt sind, die dann.
Genau, die in unseren sichtbaren Bereich reingebracht werden, um einfach eine Vorstellung von einer Strahlungsaktivität zu haben, die aber jetzt,
so direkt sichtbar, wenn man jetzt irgendwo an der passenden Stelle auf so einem
Raumfahrtsessel im All sitzen würde, würde man's so nicht sehen. Es sei denn, wir hätten halt Augen, die einfach einen größeren ein größeres Spektrum abdecken und das ist eigentlich genau das, was damit ja simuliert wird.
Da ist es vielleicht wichtig zu wissen, dass die Schärfe eines Bildes ja von der Größe des Spiegels abhängt und von der Wellenlänge,
und es ist so tatsächlich, dass James Web wird im Infrarotten Licht ungefähr die gleichen scharfen Bilder erzeugen wie Hable im sichtbaren Licht.
Hat ja auch eine Infrarotkamera, also James Rap wird nicht zum ersten Mal Bilder im Infraroten machen. Aber die Auflösung der Habbelbilder im Infrarotten ist ungefähr fünfmal schlechter als im sichtbaren, weil einfach die Wellenlänge.
Und es, ja, mhm.
Das heißt also, James Web wird letztendlich dieselbe Schärfe an Bildern bekommen, wie Hable, wie wir sie von den Habelbildern,
gewöhnt sind. Aber es wird im Infrarotbereich ungefähr 1hundert Mal empfindlicher sein, also es wird viel, viel schwächere Objekte sehen können, viel, viel mehr Strukturen, viel genauer alles sehen können.
jetzt war's schon so in die in die wissenschaftlichen Ziele abgeglitten. Ähm,
Trotzdem vielleicht schließen wir das einfach mal mit den Instrumenten ab und sprechen noch mal kurz da drüber, wie James Web jetzt denn auch seinen Dienst antreten
wird. außer diesen vier Instrumenten und dem Spiegel an sich gibt's noch weitere Komponenten in diesem System, die nennenswert sind.
Also es gibt noch natürlich die Dinge, die benötigt werden, um das Ding überhaupt zu betreiben und am Himmel auszurichten. Also es gibt einen Feinguiden-Sensor,
es gibt natürlich die ganze Lagerregelungskontrolle, also mit den Spiegeln und den Trallrädern und Entschuldigung nicht spiegeln mit dem mit den.
Und so weiter. wichtig ist auch zu wissen, dass James Web ähm.
Seine Manöver sozusagen, wenn es von einem Stern auf den anderen gerichtet wird, dass das mithilfe von Kaltgas Düsen gemacht.
Also nicht zum Beispiel wie Rosat, der im praktisch nur mit den Trallrädern und mit magnetischen Kräften gearbeitet hat, sondern da draußen, wo James Web fliegt, beim L2 Punkt gibt's ja
fast keine Magnetfelder. und deswegen muss man dort andere Techniken benutzen. Also man hat Kaltgas.
Und das Kaltgas hat natürlich den Nachteil, dass es sich verbraucht, das heißt, es gibt also ein ein Verbrauchselement, das ist das irgendwann mal,
James Web nicht mehr hin und her wackeln kann. wir hoffen, dass also es ist mindestens fünf Jahre, aber wir hoffen, dass wir's so sparsam einsetzen können,
geschickte Missionsplanung, dass wir das wahrscheinlich auf zehn Jahre verlängern können, aber leider ist dadurch die Lebensdauer von dem Teleskop begrenzt.
Und auch absehbar begrenzt, also da ist dann auch nicht mehr so viel dran zu machen. Es sei denn, man.
Wenn nicht ein Wunder geschieht.
Nicht so viel, aber will sich ja bewegen, man will ja eigentlich auch überall hinschauen, ja
das hat mir so auch jetzt noch gar nicht erwähnt, beziehungsweise nur
am Rande, also wie herrschel und blank und befindet sich des Teleskop an diesem Langepunkt zwei, also quasi dem Punkt hinter der Erde, wo sich die,
Gravitation der Erde und der Sonne aufheben, so dass dort eben Objekte mehr oder weniger mit der Erde
mitfliegen können, ohne jetzt permanent noch einen eigenen Antrieb zu haben oder sich gegen andere Kräfte so groß wehren zu müssen. Ich vermute mal, es wird auch so eine ähnliche Art und Weise, wie bei den anderen Missionen laufen, dass man da irgendwie so eine.
Figur.
So eine Raum 8 ähfliegt quasi, um so eine gewisse Stabilität zu haben, also man orbitet sozusagen um so einen, ja, um so einen mathematischen Punkt herum.
Da ist vielleicht wichtig zu wissen, man, wenn man genau in diesem Punkt sitzen würde, dann würde ja die Erde, die Sonne abschaffen sozusagen, dann würde man keinen Strom auf seine Solarzellen bekommen, deswegen muss man also auch ein Stückchen weiter außen fliegen, damit die die Sonne.
Wäre das wirklich so? Also ist denn die Erde dann so groß, dass sie die Sonne auch komplett verdecken würde in dieser großen Distanz? Also ist da wirklich ein richtiger Schatten? Also quasi wie im Mund Finsternis.
Wie eine Mondfinsternis sozusagen, ja. Deswegen sind diese.
Also eine Erdfinsternis wäre das sozusagen, ja. Mhm.
Sind diese Bahnen, die man da in L2 fliegt doch ganz schön groß. Die sind, glaube ich, achthunderttausend Kilometer oder irgendwie sowas. Also der Radius der Erde ist ja 6000 Kilometer und meist also ungefähr zehn Mal weiter draußen als die der Schatten der Erde.
Da muss man natürlich dann auch erstmal hinkommen und wenn man da ist, dann ist auch klar, da sind dann so Reparaturmissionen wahrscheinlich nicht so möglich, zumindest wie so derzeit der Stand der Technik ist, ne?
Wenn nicht ein Wunder passiert, also im Moment gibt's ja keine astronatische Raumfahrt jenseits ähm.
der Erdbeeren beziehungsweise der Bahn. Wir wollen zum Mond fliegen wieder und man könnte sich träumen, dass man vielleicht irgendwann auch mal zum L zwei fliegen könnte, aber bisher ist es noch nicht wirklich im Gespräch.
Im Prinzip lief das ja auf eine robotische Mission hinaus, wenn man da irgendwas reparieren wollen würde. Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass Jan Schwepp jetzt unbedingt dafür.
Gebaut ist, automatisiert repariert zu werden. Immer ist ja ein sehr filigranes Gebilde. Wir haben das ja so noch gar nicht angesprochen. Also diese Kühlung
die hier stattfindet oder beziehungsweise die Abschirmung der Sonne, um eben einen Aufwärmen der Instrumente zu verhindern, sind riesige
wandte mehrlagige Folien oder mehrere Lagen von einzelnen Folien. Wie sind's drei, vier,
fünf Stück, genau. das heißt also, man kann sich das wahrscheinlich wirklich so vorstellen, wie so aufgespannte Alufolie, die quasi hinter diesen Instrumenten fliegt immer die Sonne im Rücken hat, aber wo kommt denn dann die Solar.
Energie her.
Die Solarzellen schauen, also dieser diese dieser Sonnenschirm sozusagen ist so etwas länglich äh.
Der ist auf der einen Seite muss natürlich so groß sein wie das Teleskop, auf der anderen Seite ist er etwas länger und die Solarzellen schauen dann da.
Einfach links und rechts raus. Okay.
Ich vergleich das manchmal, weil im Moment ist ja das dritte dann sozusagen.
Einge in sich selbst verpuppt, also es ist der Spiegel ist zusammengeklappt, diese Solar äh.
Die der Sonnenschutz ist hochgeklappt und das Ganze ist extrem feines feine Plastikfolie,
Ich vergleich das manchmal so mit dem einem Schmetterling, der sozusagen komplett in einer Puppe versteckt ist und dann geht diese
auf und dann entfalten sich die Flügel. Und so ungefähr ist es bei James Web auch nur, dass eben diese Flügel fünflagig sind. Die müssen sich nun nicht nur entfalten
die müssen auch mit Motoren dann sozusagen auf Abstand gehalten werden, dass dazwischen
Vakuum ist, weil nur durch diese fünf verschiedenen also absolut getrennten Schichten kann dann die Wärmestrahlung auch abgehalten werden.
Das ist ja auch so noch nie gemacht worden.
Nee und das war eben auch eins der Gründe, warum das dann letztendlich doch so viel länger gedauert hat, das zusammenzubauen. Also erstens haben sie.
Gestellt, dass es ähm.
Das sind tausende von Mieten, mit denen das irgendwie festgelegt wurde, da gab's also ein Produktionsproblem mit den Nieten, sieht beim Schütteln, beim rausgefallen und musste das ganze Ding völlig neu
aufgebaut werden. Das andere ist, dass dann wenn zu große Kräfte wirken, dass diese extrem dünnen Plastikfolien dann reißen. Da musste also auch an Stellen gewissen Stellen verstärkt werden
Also es ist ein sehr empfindliches und defiziles Gerät dieser Sonnenschutz.
Mhm. Plastikfolien sind das.
Bisschen Meiler. Es sind, glaube ich, beschichtete Meilerfolien, also extrem dünne.
Bedampft sind mit.
Ja, genau, ein Mikrometer, wahrscheinlich ja genau, bedampfte äh.
Mhm. Im Prinzip auch so kleine Spiegel, wa, den werden nicht als solche gebraucht, sondern soll halt nur die Wärme zurückspiegeln.
Ja, der Staat haben wir schon erwähnt,
wird mit ja auch von der ISA durchgeführt, ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht etwas ungewöhnlich, würde man meinen, nicht vermute mal,
etwas damit zu tun, dass die Transportkapazität der Ariane fünf zu dem Zeitpunkt als man selbst starten wollte, so bei den Amerikanern auch gar nicht,
vorlag. Das ändert sich ja gerade, aber das war wahrscheinlich der Grund, oder?
Und auch, dass die Ariane fünf eine speziell große Ferien hat, also die die Ferien, also das ist sozusagen die Kapsel, in der das Teleskop eingepuppt ist, ähm
die muss ja diesen riesen Spiegel auffassen und zu dem Zeitpunkt als beschlossen wurde
James Rap von der ISA zu starten. Da da hat das eben die Kombination des ähm
also die Startkapazität, die das Gewicht ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so das Problem, aber die große ist war also eine einzigartige.
Geschichte und Winterferien hatten wir dann ja auch etliche noch zusätzliche Konstruktionen durchführen müssen, mussten also noch Verbesserungen,
Ferien anführen, die können wir, da können wir nachher noch drauf eingehen.
Ja, gehen wir noch mal drauf ein, weil ich finde ja, diesen Staat interessant. Ich meine, in letzter Zeit hat der europäische Raumfahrt, was jetzt Staats betrifft,
Mal eine Menge Konkurrenz bekommen
kommen, ja? Also SpaceX ich hatte es ja auch neulich im Programm, ist zweifelsohne einfach ein sehr, sehr, sehr erfolgreiches Projekt
geworden und nimmt auch an Entwicklungsbeschleunigung nicht ab und ist auch sehr zuverlässig. Bis dahin galt halt vor allem das Arianeprogramm als extrem Zufall ist, wie man das glaube ich,
das, was das ganze Ariane Programm ausgezeichnet hat, bis es.
Vor ein paar Jahren mal überhaupt nach langer, langer Zeit mal überhaupt wieder ein Problem gab, aber die Zuverlässigkeit dieses Systems spielt natürlich dann auch eine Rolle bei der Auswahl.
Also es ist schon so, die Arianne ist sehr zuverlässig, aber sie ist nicht die zuverlässigste von allen Raketen. Also es gibt im Prinzip auch die Atlas Rakete zum Beispiel jetzt auch sehr, sehr zuverlässig. Ähm,
Wir sind froh, dass die alle so zuverlässig sind, weil ansonsten könnte man diese extrem teuren Missionen überhaupt nicht planen.
Aber auch der Standort ist da sicherlich ein ein Faktor, also als bester Weltraumbahnbahnhof für so.
Ist auch ein Element. also es ist so diese Entscheidung, James Web auf einer europäischen Rakete zu fliegen, die ist nicht bei allen wirklich mit Freude aufgenommen worden, also insbesondere die amerikanischen Raketenfirmen waren nicht besonders begeistert,
aber es ist halt so, es ist James Rap ist eine internationale Partnerschaft und bei so einer Partnerschaft muss jeder,
Dinge einbringen können, die also wirklich auch kritisch sind, also nicht nur sozusagen Händchen halten, sondern wirklich aktiv und und an vorderster Front mit dabei sein und da ist eben der Start.
Da sind wir unheimlich stolz und sind uns auch der Verantwortung bewusst, dass das das Wertvollste,
schwierigste Projekt ist, was uns je vertraut wurde sozusagen oder anvertraut wurde.
Mhm. Was sind denn diese speziellen Anpassungen, die da gemacht werden mussten?
Also es hat sich rausgestellt, dass bei dieser Entfaltung,
der die diese extrem empfindlichen Schichten für den für die Sonnensegel.
Für den Sonnenschutz sozusagen, dass dort Kräfte auftreten, die man versuchen muss zu minimieren und zwar das wird ja sozusagen unter,
normalen Atmosphärenbedingungen verpackt. Da ist also praktisch Luft zwischen diesen verschiedenen Schichten.
Und wenn man, wenn die Ferien aufgeht und das Ding ausgesetzt wird, dann ist da plötzlich Vakuum,
Und die wir hatten eine Zeit lang Angst, dass weil ja die Ferien sozusagen schlagartig aufgeht, also dass das nicht so langsam geht, sondern,
Instantantan, dass dann einige von diesen Luftblasen mehr oder weniger platzen und vielleicht den, diese dünne Haut verletzen. Das heißt also, es ging darum
möglichst schon während des Aufstiegs,
Das Vakuum reinzulassen oder die Luft rauszulassen und dazu mussten ganz spezielle Vorkehrungen getroffen werden. Also es mussten spezielle Lüftungs Schlitze dort eingefügt werden. Und wir haben mehrere.
Ariane Staat gehabt, wo wir dann ganz empfindliche Drucksensoren in die Ferien eingebaut haben, um sozusagen den Differenzdruck dort zu messen.
Wir hatten vorher nie diese Anforderungen, deswegen waren die europäischen Drucksensoren ungefähr zehn Mal weniger empfindlich als notwendig wäre, um überhaupt,
zu messen. Deswegen haben wir dann von den Amerikanern, von der NASA, empfindlichere Drucksensoren bekommen, die wir eingebaut haben und dann in mehreren vorhergehenden Starts ähm
praktisch getestet haben. Es hat sich herausgestellt, dass wir nicht ganz die Wunsch ähm.
Den Wunschdruck erreicht haben. Also wir sind ungefähr ein Faktor zwei immer noch schlechter als das, was die NASA ursprünglich eigentlich wollte.
Deswegen ist die NASA zurückgegangen und hat an einigen besonders empfindlichen Stellen diese Plastikfolien nochmal.
die Plastikfolie sozusagen nochmal verstärkt. Also es war ein interativer Prozess, wo wir versucht haben, sowohl das Teleskop zu so sicher zu machen, als auch die Ferien sicher zu machen.
Mhm. Wie verläuft denn dann der Start? Ich meine, ähm.
Man hat erstmal so die erste Stufe, die wird ja schnell losgetrennt, dann wird mit einer zweiten Stufe ja normalerweise dann ein Orbit erreicht, wenn man jetzt halt eine eine Orbitmission hat.
wann öffnet sich denn diese wann ist es denn wirklich nur noch das letzte Objekt, was die.
Die die wir gehen ja auf direkt auf ein Escape Orbit sozusagen. Ähm,
Und die die die Ferien öffnet sich dann relativ schnell und die Separation des Teleskops von der zweiten Stufe findet dann auch schon innerhalb von,
den ersten ein, zwei Stunden statt, das heißt also, man ist ziemlich schnell schon hoffentlich auf dem Weg.
Wird dann das System auch schon vollständig entfaltet.
Und dann geht's eben los, dann entfalten sich als erstes die oder die Solarzellen.
Also ich vergleiche das immer so ein bisschen, die Nase hat doch diese wunderschöne Landung, mehrere, mehrfach schon geschafft, also von den,
Mars-Rovern auf dem Mars und da gibt's ja so also eine ganze ineinander verschachtelte Sequenz von Fallschirm und Bremsraketen.
Neun Minuten des auf Terror, ja?
In unserem Fall ist es so, dass es fast 14 Tage Terror sind. Das heißt also, die ersten 14 Tage.
Müssen sich insgesamt fünfzig Mechanismen mit mit über, weiß nicht, vierhundert Motoren ja,
50 aktivierte Mechanismen müssen funktionieren.
Und das ist halt das Problem. Also wenn wenn man hundert Prozent Erfolg haben muss, dann muss jede einzelne dieser Mechanismen muss auch äh,
neunundneunzig Komma neun neun Prozent sicher sein. Und also als erstes, wie gesagt, entfalten sich die Solarzellen.
Dann wird dieser extrem empfindliche Mechanismus des,
Tennisfeld großen Sonnenschirms ausgefaltet. wenn der ausgefaltet ist, dann müssen diese fünf Schichten sozusagen über Motoren einzeln aufgespannt werden. Also der der muss ja dann.
Gespannt werden,
Dann wenn das passiert ist, dann wird der Mast, auf dem das Teleskop sich befindet, irgendwie angehoben, weil erst dann kann sich das das Spiegelsystem entfalten, also,
der Mast angefangen. Dann das ist ja fast wie so ein dreiflügliger Altar, also man hat den Spiegel praktisch in in drei Schichten, der die C zwei äußeren Flügel müssen sich dann auffalten.
Und dann als letztes muss äh,
Sekundärspiegel rausgefaltet werden, der Sekundärspiegel, der ist auf so einem drei dreifach System, was zusammengeklappt ist und das muss also rausgefahren werden, damit das Licht dann da drauf äh.
Kleinere Spiegel, der den großen aus diesen Hexagon zusammengesetzten Gesamtspiegel gegenüber steht, wo das Licht dann quasi erst mal reingeleuchtet wird, um dann wieder zurück.
In die Instrumente.
Die Instrumente zu kommen.
Wenn man dann soweit ist, dann muss jeder einzelne dieser Spiegel, der ist ja sozusagen an Motoren aufgehängt, muss also auf ähm,
nanometer genau an die richtige Position gefahren werden,
Da wird man vermutlich schon die ersten Bilder nehmen, das da wird man, so ähnlich wie wir das am sehen, da werden wir Bilder sehen, wo jeder einzelne Spiegel ein einzelnes Sternbild erzeugt und dann muss man diese Sternbilder alle,
zusammenbringen und das passiert auch, also letztendlich wird.
Die ganze Kommissionsphase und diese ganze Test- und Kalibrationsphase wird ungefähr ein halbes Jahr dauern.
Und dann hoffentlich so Mitte nächsten Jahres, Ende Juni werden dann auch die ersten wirklichen wissenschaftlichen Beobachtungen stattfinden.
Und dann erst weiß man eigentlich, dass alles.
Alles funktioniert.
Funktioniert, aber ich denke, wenn man die ersten 14 Tage dann erstmal überlebt hat und das Ding so an sich in der Konstellation ist, dann beginnt wahrscheinlich auch so dieser Bereich, wo man dann mit äh,
mit dieser üblichen Anpassungskunst, die so entwickelt wird, kleinere Probleme gegebenenfalls auch nochmal umschiffen kann, so denn eben das Gesamtsystem funktioniert.
So, das heißt, die Reise zu dem L zwei selbst dauert jetzt eigentlich gar nicht so lang.
die Reise bin ich jetzt nicht ganz bin ich etwas überfragt, aber ich glaube, die ist also am Ende der 14 Tage sind wir dann auch am Superfunk angekommen, also nach dem.
Mhm. Ja und dann noch ein halbes Jahr einmessen und dann geht's los mit dem Spaß. habe mich gerade noch gefragt, ob denn.
Es sind also wenn das limitierende Element diese der Treibstoffe, diese Kaltgasdüsen ist,
ob's denn in irgendeiner Form
vorgesehen ist, zumindest für eine theoretische, zukünftige Entwicklung so eine Art Nachbetankung vorzunehmen. Also wäre das System überhaupt andockt
Bar, also gibt es die Möglichkeit, Treibstoff zuzuführen, wo man denn in der Lage wäre, ein entsprechendes Vehikel dorthin zu transportieren.
Das wäre toll, aber da muss ich mich jetzt ein bisschen zurückhalten. das also ich ich gehe davon aus, dass es möglich ist, aber ich habe also keine keinerlei sagen wir mal Bestätigung dafür.
Ja gut, aber es ist sozusagen nicht so, dass ich jetzt erst auf die Idee gekommen bin.
Nein, es sind auch andere Leute, die dadrüber nachdenken.
Okay. Das wäre doch toll. Ja, weil ich meine, das ist so immer so ein bisschen traurig eigentlich, dass man sieht, dass diese Technik ja eigentlich.
Sehr, sehr gut funktionieren. Also Habbel hält lange durch. es gibt so viele Beispiele. Man kann ja eigentlich fast jede Mission nennen.
Die sehr, sehr lange durchhält und das
obwohl grad so viel an der Elektronik hängt und die ja da in so einem strahlenbar wirklich permanent geduscht wird, schon ein Wunder, dass das überhaupt alles so gut funktioniert und dann ist halt irgendwann der Treibstoff alles so, aber das Auto würde ja noch.
Und von daher denke ich mal, wäre das eine schöne Entwicklung, die die Raumfahrt da noch nehmen könnte, wenn dieses Problem mal irgendwann generell genutzt.
Also sagen wir mal so, wir wir haben ja dasselbe Problem nicht nur bei James Web, sondern auch bei vielen anderen Missionen, also XM Newton bei uns zum Beispiel.
Da hieß es früher auch, okay, der Treibstoff wird dann so und so lange da erhalten.
Aber inzwischen haben die Leute, die das Teleskop betreiben, so viel tricksige Konzepte erfunden,
Treibstoff ungefähr dreimal so lang gehalten hat wie ursprünglich gedacht war. Also das das ist eine Hoffnung, die ich auch habe, dass man
das wirklich optimieren kann, also die die Industrie
und auch die Leute, die das Teleskop bauen, bauen da ja auch immer gewisse Sicherheiten ein. Also wenn wenn das heißt, es muss mindestens fünf Jahre funktionieren, dann gehe ich davon aus, dass sie das so machen, dass es zehn Jahre und ähm
dann kann man vielleicht durch sehr, sehr genaue Planungen und so weiter das Ganze noch minimieren, also ich habe da große Hoffnungen, die,
also zum Beispiel indem man eben nicht wild am Himmel herumfährt, sondern immer nur ganz kleine Stücke fährt bis zum nächsten Tage, also man kann durch die Missionsplanung das auch beeinflussen.
Ja, wollte ich leider sagen, ne, die waren einfach nicht sich zu viel dreht, sondern ähm.
Genau, ja. Aber der Punkt ist Betrankung im im Weltraum, hat ja im Prinzip schon stattgefunden, also die Esa hat ja,
zum Beispiel Treibstoff zur Raumstation hochgebracht, das heißt also das Konzept des Betankens im Weltraum ist im Prinzip,
entwickelt und das ist jetzt eigentlich nur eine Frage, wie man's genau macht. Das.
Aber nicht vollständig robotisch. Ich meine, da ist ja dann noch die Mithilfe der Astronauten gefragt.
In dem Fall war das so, ja und das stimmt, ja.
Sonst muss sich noch einer opfern und missfliegen. Nein, natürlich.
Gut, dann können wir ja mal noch wieder zur wissenschaftlichen Nutzung und den zu erwarten, denn Ergebnissen mal kommen. vielleicht eine Sache, die ich noch gern aufgreifen würde, wie das Projekt so aufgestellt ist, weil,
Okay, ist ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt. Isa ist irgendwie dabei. NASA ist dabei. Wie funktioniert es?
Kanada ist auch dabei, ja.
Ja genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, es sind sicherlich nicht die einzigen, also wer spielt da eine Rolle? Wer ist fehlerführend, wer greift an welcher Stelle rein? Wie ist das aufgeteilt?
Also so ähnlich wie bei Hubble ist es so, dass die NASA praktisch die Haupt Führung hat, die die größten Größenanteil finanziert
einen Juniorpartner ist, also im Fall von Habel waren das so, dass
ungefähr 15 Prozent der Beiträge gebracht hat und bei James Web war's eigentlich auch so, also.
Dass wir die Juniorpartner bei einem NASA Flagship sind. So was ähnliches gab's früher auch schon bei Casini Holgens, wo wo wir gemeinsam zum Saturn geflogen sind,
dann hat Isa eben eine wichtige Komponente beigestellt, aber der die Führung war bei der NASA,
Aber wir kennen auch umgekehrte Projekte. Wir haben zum Beispiel hat uns grade die NASA den gestartet. Der ist von Florida ausgestattet worden. Das ist ein ISA-Projekt, wo die NASA-Juniorpartner ist. Also es ist ein bisschen.
Aber fast gegengespiegelt, dass er da Solo arbeitet, haben wir der NASA anvertraut, sie hat's für uns exzellent gestartet
wir hoffen's umgehend. Und und auch bei so einer Orwetter hat die NASA ein Instrument beigestellt und wir stellen jetzt bei ähm,
James Web, einen Halbinstrument dabei, also Niersbeck und die Hälfte von von Miri.
Und dann kommt der Staat dazu und es kommt dazu, dass wir eine Reihe von sowas wie zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen haben, die in Baltimore sozusagen,
persönlich bei noch Beiträge leisten, also das ist auch so wie beim Hubble.
Das da wird der der ganze Betrieb von Space Telescop Science Institut in Baltimore betrieben, aber die Isar ist dort praktisch vor Ort mit Personal vertreten, um dann auch,
beizu tragen und auch zu partizipieren.
Und die Kanada hat ungefähr so was wie vier oder fünf Prozent Beitrag mit diesem Instrument geliefert.
Mhm. Okay, ähm.
Sind jetzt alles funktioniert hat und das Instrument ist am Start und ist dann alles kalibriert. Wer macht eigentlich die die Missions ähm.
nee, die die Missionssteuer, also nach dem nach dem Staat, das macht dann auch das Esog.
Nein, in dem Fall ist es so, dass der Betrieb direkt vom Institut in Baltimore gemacht wird. Das heißt
also die das für uns wichtigste Signal Equizision of Signal, dass also die ersten Daten wirklich runterkommen. Das würde ist in diesem Fall läuft das komplett über die USA,
Während es bei den ISA-Missionen eben über uns läuft, also.
Ah okay. Also wenn wenn sozusagen das Signal kommt, dann ist Ariannisbass und Esa ist dann erstmal raus, so.
Ist schon raus in dem Moment, wo sie uns getrennt haben, dann gehen die nach Hause. bei uns geht dann diese, wie gesagt, diese 14 Tage Terror erstmal los, aber der,
erste Aufregung nach dem Start wird dann tatsächlich von Baltimore aus sein. Also es wird auch ein interessante Choreografie,
der ganzen Videobotschaften sein, also wir werden ja ein Teil der Leute wird in Koru sein, relativ wenig diesmal,
Es wird dann in Washington und hier auch beim Essdeck eine große also nicht öffentlich, aber große Veranstaltung, wo wir wissen, nicht in alle einladen, die da dran beteiligt waren. und dann wird's im Baltimore eben äh,
gewisses kleines Team geben, was dann tatsächlich die ersten Daten sich anschaut. Und die Choreografie wäre jetzt wann, auf welchem Bildschirm sozusagen im Fernsehen erscheint. Das ist wird in der Vorbereitung jetzt im Moment grade.
Mhm. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, die komplette Raumfahrtszene der Welt wird an dem Tag einfach mal den Kugelschreiber beiseite legen.
Zuschauen, ja.
Also das das ist schon ein großes Ereignis.
So, was ist denn jetzt womit geht's denn los? Also es ist ja hier auch Teil der Arbeit am am E-Sack, diese ganze astronomische und wissenschaftliche Arbeit dieser Mission ähm
aufzuteilen, zu koordinieren und festzulegen, wer kriegt jetzt die Daten oder die Daten überhaupt erstmal in Empfang zu nehmen und dann weiter zu verteilen? Wie wird das beim James Web Teleskop laufen und was zeichnet sich jetzt ab
was so die ersten Dinge sind, auf die man blicken möchte. Man wird ja wahrscheinlich die interessantesten Sachen dann auch gleich als erstes angehen, oder?
Also zunächst ist es so, dass ja die Beobachtungszeit dann an diesen ganzen Teleskopen,
öffentlich ausgeschrieben wird, dann da kann man sich also mit einem guten, jeder, der eine gute Idee hat, kann sich da bewerben. Und diese sogenannte of Opportunity für die Allgemeinheit,
Die hat ja schon vor mehr als einem Jahr hat die stattgefunden und dort wurden also dann.
Sechs oder sieben Mal mehr Vorschläge eingereicht als wir im ersten Jahr durchführen konnten und die Verteilung der Beobachtungszeit, das ist dann immer fast wie Weihnachten, wenn dann die Nachricht bekommt, wer bekommt, Beobachtungszeiten, wer nicht.
Zusätzlich muss man dazu sagen, dass bei allen diesen Teleskopen, wo die wo irgendwelche Institute oder Länder,
Beiträge geliefert haben, also Instrumente zum Beispiel, dann haben diese Konsortien, die diese Instrumente bauen, haben auch ein gewisses Recht an prioritären Beobachtungszeiten, das ist die sogenannte Garantiezeit.
Dem ersten eineinhalb Jahren oder so oder im ersten Jahr,
wird dann als erstes die Garantiezeit abgearbeitet und dann kommen die öffentlichen oder offenen Beobachtungen. Bei der Garantiezeit, da ist es so, dass die Konsortien.
Sozusagen vorab schon sagen müssen, was sie besonders beobachten. Und es ist klar, dass zum Beispiel die, die Kamera gebaut haben,
werden im Wesentlichen die ersten sehr, sehr tiefen Bilder machen, also die die sozusagen am weitesten hinaus schauen, da da geht ja sehr viel.
rein,
die, die den Spektograph gebaut haben, werden sich im Wesentlichen konzentrieren auf Dinge, zum Beispiel, die dieses auf auf Exo-Planeten, die dort beobachtet werden. Da.
Gibt es jetzt schon diese sogenannten goldenen Targets, die identifiziert wurden, die von James Web dann angeschaut werden.
Also die ganzen Highlights, die so in den letzten zehn Jahren diskutiert wurden in der.
Ja, also ich vermute mal, Trapp ist eins oder Keops hat gerade ein wunderschönes, goldenes Ei entdeckt, was wir vorher noch nicht kannte. Das wird auf jeden Fall mit James Web angeschaut werden
Aber wenn man jetzt mal auf die mehr allgemeine Beobachtung schaut, also auf dieses eine Jahr, was jetzt schon verteilt wurde, dann ist es eigentlich auch sehr schön zu sehen, dass die ganzen wichtigen Themen wirklich vertreten sind
Und eine Sache wollte ich noch sagen, wir haben, obwohl Europa,
etwa 15 Prozent Anteile hat, haben wir ungefähr 30 Prozent der Beobachtungszeit nach Europa holen können.
Das liegt im Wesentlichen da dran, glaube ich, dass wir sehr intensiv schon die Community geschult haben. Wir haben Masterclasses irgendwie in den verschiedenen Ländern
bespielt, wir sind nach Polen gefahren nach also überall hin und haben dort lokal vor Ort die Leute trainiert und heiß gemacht ja,
Und ich glaube, das wird in den also in den folgenden Jahren nicht mehr so so gut laufen, aber wir hatten da so ein bisschen die Nase vorn
wenn man sich in USA anschaut, das sind diese
Beobachtungen dann auch immer mit Finanzierung verknüpft, also wenn jemand viel beobachtet bekommt, bekommt er auch Geld, um zum Beispiel einen Doktoranden oder einen damit zu finanzieren.
Deswegen ist es bei den Amerikanern auch so eine Art existenzielles Problem. Also wo stecken sie am meisten Energie rein? Wo wo erhöhen sie die Chancen am besten,
sich fit zu finanzieren,
die waren also da noch ein bisschen zögerlich im Verhältnis zu den Europäern, die also gleich voll losmarschiert sind. Und es gibt also,
einige sogenannte kosmologische tiefe Felder am Himmel, die schon in anderen Wellen mit anderen Projekten sehr, sehr,
untersucht worden sind, so zum Beispiel das Kosmosfeld, das Kosmosfeld ist ein zwei Quadrat großes Feld am Himmel.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen, der der Vollmond hat ein halbes Grad und sie können also den Vollmond ungefähr sechzehn Mal da reinpacken, dann ist es so ein Quadrat am Himmel, was also von,
von, von Spitze, von XM Newton, also alles, was Rang und Namen hat, schon zu Tode beobachtet wurde. Und dieses Feld wird auch von James Web äh.
Ist aber jetzt nicht dieses.
Ist ein kleineres Feld, das kriegt auch Beobachtungszeit, aber das am meisten James Web Beobachtungszeit geht in das Kosmosfeld. und das Interessante dadran ist,
diese Daten auch sofort publik werden, also die werden sofort der der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung gestellt. Ähm
Während in den meisten anderen Fällen hat der Beobachter ungefähr ein Jahr Zeit, sich mit den Daten exklusiv.
Also in dem Fall des Kosmosfeldes. Mhm.
Genau. Das Kosmos fällt und ich glaube auch, dass und auch noch das. Also es gibt drei wie ich wichtige sogenannte kosmologische Felder.
Aber am meisten Beobachtungszeit von James Web geht erstmal in das Kosmosfeld.
Ist das schon so ein bisschen so ein Trend, nicht, dass man diesen exklusiven Zugriff von bestimmten Wissenschaftlern auf bestimmte Beobachtungsdaten fürn Anfangszeitraum, dass sich das mehr in so eine allgemeine freie Bereitstellung hält. Also wir haben's ja bei der App
Beobachtung bei Kopernikus ist es ja quasi Programm. ist das so ein Trend?
Also bei ich möchte, dass Geier möchte ich als Beispiel bringen. Geier hat ja keinerlei ähm,
garantiert, also beziehungsweise limitierte Beobachtungszeit, sondern da werden die Daten ausgewertet und sofort in die
Allgemeinheit gestorben. Allerdings ist es so, dass man um die Geierdaten auszuwerten, muss man alle Daten gleichzeitig auswerten. Das ist ein riesen Aufwand und das heißt, das dauert jetzt eher lang, bis die überhaupt fertig ausgewertet sind. Aber in dem Moment, wo sie ausgewertet sind,
hat kein Wissenschaftler ein Vorrecht, sondern die gehen sofort raus. Und wir sehen das bei jeder,
Veröffentlichung, da gibt's also explosionsartig auf der ganzen Welt ziehen sich die da die Leute die Daten runter und wir sind fest davon überzeugt, dass die der Erfolg, den Geier hat, mit den 1600 Publikationen pro pro Jahr.
Dass das auch daran hängt, dass die Daten sofort publik wurden.
Und so ähnlich ist es ja auch am Anfang mit dem gemacht worden, dass man sozusagen die Daten sofort publik macht und das das hat sich eigentlich in den kosmologischen Feldern,
Ist das jetzt der Standard, dass also alles, was sozusagen tief und breit beobachtet wird, sofort publik werden.
interessanterweise hat sich auch eine,
der Gruppen die Garantiezeitbeobachtung bekommt, nämlich die Kollegin Heidi Hamel, die sich hauptsächlich die Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem anschaut,
Die haben beschlossen, dass sie ihre Daten auch sofort publik machen. Das heißt also alle Planeten, Jupiter, Saturn, Neptun, Uranus, sie werden praktisch sofort frei sein.
Und damit glaube ich erhöht man sozusagen die Aufmerksamkeit und die Begeisterung der Leute, weil sie sich halt sofort damit beschäftigen können. Eine gewisse Gefahr ist vielleicht am Anfang.
Die Daten noch nicht hundertprozentig verstanden sind, dass es da noch systematische Fehler geben könnte und so weiter, die dann erst rausgeschüttelt werden müssen, aber das hat man in dem Fall einfach das Risiko nimmt man auf sich und gibt die Daten.
Über Exo-Planeten und den Blick in die Tiefe hat man jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal gesprochen. Neu ist ja dieser Aspekt
dass eben auch unser Sonnensystem nochmal genauer angeschaut werden soll. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, wenn man jetzt eigentlich ein Teleskop hat, was sich auf Infrarot spezialisiert, um möglichst weit zu gucken.
Warum schaut man denn ausgerechnet dann auch noch in der unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft vorbei? Was macht das James Web Teleskop denn da so geeignet?
Ja, ich hatte ja vorher gesagt, das ist nicht nur das, möglichst weit zu schauen, sondern es ist auch die Tatsache, dass zum Beispiel die Planeten ihr Maximum im Infrarotten Horn oder auch, dass man durch Schichten durchschauen kann.
Und das gilt natürlich nicht nur für Exoplaneten.
Das gilt auch für für die Planeten. Also man könnte zum Beispiel durch die obersten Schichten des Jupiter durchschauen und sehen, was sich da drunter.
befindet. und im Prinzip ist es so, dass jede,
in dem Sinn, was ich vorher gesagt habe, wenn man ein Spektrum hat, dass dann jede physikalische Information wichtig ist, also zum Beispiel gibt's eben im Infraroten wichtige,
Banden, Absorptionsbanden, von Kohlendioxid oder anderen Dingern, die es eben sichtbar nicht gibt. Also man man öffnet sozusagen ein Fenster in einen völlig neuen Raum,
die physikalischen Zusammenhänge sehen kann.
Die man überhaupt bestimmte Elemente dann erst richtig detektieren kann. Mhm. Du bist ja eigentlich komplett gefehlt haben dann, wenn man nicht Infrarot berücksichtigt.
Ja, also zum Beispiel gerade diese CO2 Banden die sind sehr, sehr wichtig in der Diagnose, was die Dichte oder die Temperatur des Materials existiert. Also die ganze
Chemie und Physik findet also Daten sehr großen Wiederhallen.
Das heißt, auch in der der Planetenforschung, also unseres Sonnensystems, verspricht man sich da komplett neue Erkenntnisse.
Und natürlich auch, wie gesagt, die Auflösung ist dann höher, zum Beispiel mit Hubble hat man ja auch schon Saturn und Jupiter angeschaut und in diesem infraroten,
Wellenlängen gesehen, aber James Web hat halt fünfmal bessere Auflösung, das heißt, man sieht alles noch viel schärfer.
Das kann einen Unterschied machen. welche Fragestellung.
Könnte man denn so, ach, würde ich sagen, werden dann beantwortet, aber es gibt ja so.
Verschiedene offene Dinge. Du Bakterien haben wir schon nebenbei angesprochen. Generell die Expansion des Universums. Es gibt ja noch so ein paar andere ähm.
Was ist so das Spektrum der Erwartbarkeit, was Web unter Umständen so mit Daten unterlegen kann, dass sich hier wirklich auch grundlegende neue Erkenntnisse formen könnten.
Also, wie gesagt, also ich möchte es mal vielleicht auf diese vier Untergebiete, also frühes Universum ähm.
Entstehungsgebiete, exoplaneten Sonnensystem. Ich selber kenne mich natürlich am besten in diesem Bereich frühes Universum aus und vielleicht.
Andere Ansprechpartner, die dann andere Gebiete vertiefen können, aber beim frühen Universum ist es eben so.
wir wir wissen heute, dass die frühesten Galaxien, die wir schon sehen können,
dass es dort Sterne gibt, die noch viel früher entstanden sein müssen, das heißt also die Frage, wann ist der erste Stern entstanden und wie ist etwas, wo James Web unheimlich viel beitragen kann,
wir wissen dass relativ früh schon schwarze Löcher existieren
Und auch die Frage, wann sind die allerersten schwarzen Löcher entstanden? Waren die schon im Rückknall da oder kamen die erste langsam? also James Rap wird letztendlich diese diesen
dunkle Phase des der allerfrühsten Sternenstehung erleuchten, wie leuchten und dort sehr viel
dann auch über die.
wie der Orgner letztendlich das Kochrezept, was der Dirk nun hinterlassen hat, erzählen. es gibt ja in der Kosmologie so gewisse Spannungsfelder, also es gibt zum Beispiel immer noch eine,
sagen wir mal Diskrepanz zwischen der Havel Constante, wie sie von,
Habl gemessen wurde und der die aus dem Mikrowellen Hintergrund herauskommt also so Feinheiten auch die vielleicht mit der Interpretation der.
Systematische Fehler zusammenhängen, da wird James Web sicher auch sehr viel.
Also kurz gesagt, man ist sich nicht einig dadrüber, wie alt das Universum jetzt wirklich ist oder wie wie sehr es sich ausdehnt, äh.
Wenn man sich die Geschichte der Hammelkonstante anschaut, dann gab's da immer Streit drum. also die einen sagten, die ist hundert, die andere sagten, die ist fünfzig und das wäre dann so, dass das,
Alter des Universums plötzlich doppelt so alt wurde. Inzwischen sind die beiden Camps schon auf ungefähr,
zehn Prozent haben sie sich genähert. Also es geht jetzt nicht mehr um fundamentale, sondern um Feinheiten, aber die,
Schärfe der Diskrepanz ist nicht geringer geworden, also die streiten immer noch genauso viel, weil die Messungen selbst immer genauer werden.
Und irgendetwas, also mir mir kommt es sowohl bei der Hamel Konstante, also bei einigen diesen Spannungsfeldern in der Kosmologie,
als auch bei der Tatsache, dass wir die dunkle Energie noch überhaupt nicht verstehen. Kommt so ein bisschen so vor, als würde uns noch ein fundamentales ähm,
Element fehlen. Also, so ein bisschen.
Wie damals vor 100 Jahren alle nach dem Äther gesucht haben und dann Einstein gesagt hat, Leute, ihr müsst die die Gleichungen umstellen, dann braucht ihr keinen Äther mehr. das das uns irgendwo noch so eine so eine Aha im Element.
Ja, so ein Denkfehler. Mhm. Vielleicht auch.
Und dieses diese Idee, die die wir da im Moment verfolgen, ob nicht vielleicht die schwarzen Löcher schon im Rückdall entstanden sind, könnte so ein.
Element sein, wo manche Dinge auf den Kopf gestellt werden, wo man das nochmal neu bewerten müsste. Und deswegen glaube ich, dass also James Web sozusagen der erste Schritt in die Richtung sein könnte, das zu.
Klarheit zu bekommen.
Abzuschießen oder zu bestätigen.
Sternenstehung, warum ist das so interessant? Also, ich meine, es ist natürlich immer alles interessant, aber.
worauf will man da spezifisch hinaus, was man derzeit noch nicht.
Also die Sternenenstehung haben wir festgestellt, wenn man zum Beispiel diese wunderschönen Havelbilder von den ähm,
Pillers of Creation anschaut oder auch von von dem Pferdekopfnebel oder von anderen. die Sternenstehung findet oft in sehr, sehr tief eingebetteten Systemen, also wo praktisch Gas und Staubwolken sich zusammenklumpen. Da,
besonders viel Gravitation da, dort kann's passieren, dass also gewisse Gebiete unter ihrem eigenen,
ihre eigenen Schwerkraft zusammenstürzen und dann Sterne bilden. Und das findet halt hinter einem dicken Vorhang statt und da kann man so nicht reinschauen.
Und da würde eben,
James so ähnlich wie schon angefangen hat, da wird James Web also sehr sehr tief in die eingebetteten Strukturen reinschauen können. Und da geht's insbesondere auch darum.
Die sogenannte Enisle Mass-Function, also die die Massenfunktion der Sterne, wenn sie entstehen.
Es stellt sich raus, dass es gibt ja viel mehr kleine Sterne als große Sterne, also wenn man also die das Herzrasseldiagramm anschaut, an indem die Sterne entlang ihrer Masse an also an einem solchen,
Pfad folgen, also sehr heiße Sterne sind sehr groß und strahlend blau. Ähm,
kleinere, also weniger massereiche Sterne wie die Sonne strahlend gelb und die ganz kleinen Sterne strahlen rot.
Viel mehr von diesen roten Sternen gibt als von den anderen
Aber wie viel genau, das hängt davon ab, dass man eben die roten Sterne sind viel, viel schwächer als die als die gelben und die blauen. Deswegen braucht man viel größere Teleskope, um sie wirklich äh.
Ordentlich zählen zu können.
Und ordentlich zählen zu können. Und dann natürlich auch es gibt ja so ein ähm.
Sequenz Sterne, also vor Haupt, Rheinsterne, junge Sterne, die sind noch dunkler und noch schwerer zu sehen und da ist eben diese Infrarot Kapapilität und aber auch die Auflösung. also oft ist es so,
Man sieht irgendwie was und.
Denkt, das ist ein Stern und wenn man dann genauer hinstellt, stellen wir fest, es ist fünf Sterne oder zehn oder ein ganze Sternhaufen. Da wird James Rap, also.
Mhm. Feiner auflösen und vor allem den, den jungen Stern schon zum Zeitpunkt zuschauen, wo der Motor eigentlich noch gar nicht so richtig läuft.
Richtig, genau. Und es stellt sich heraus, dass gerade diese frühen Sternenstehungsphasen auch sehr interessant sind. Da gibt es eben dann,
ähm,
Es ist ja der Dreh-Impuls dieser Materie muss sich ja, der muss ja irgendwie weggeschafft werden. das ist dann die Phase, wo Planeten entstehen, wo gleichzeitig auch Jets rauskommen, also die ganze
wie man sozusagen von dem Uhrstern dann auf das Planetensystem kommt und diese ganze Frage exoplaneten ist da sehr eng miteinander verknüpft äh
und da ich mein Alma zum Beispiel, dieses riesen Radio Teleskop, in der Atacama-Wüste, hat da schon gigantische neue,
Erfahrung gebracht, von diesen Scheiben um Sterne herum, die zum Teil dann schon von Planeten und ausgefurcht werden, wo man also wirklich zuschauen kann,
dass der Planeten entstehen. Aber die Planeten selber sieht man noch nicht. James Web könnte möglicherweise in solchen Scheiben dann den Planet selber sehen zum Beispiel,
solche Dinge. Also da ist sehr spannende gibt's noch sehr spannende Dinge.
Der ganze Exoplanetenbereich ist ja ohnehin so ein Shootingstar, wie man.
nicht wahr, man ist nun gar nicht so lange her, das war überhaupt der erste Mal deditiert wurde und dann ging die ganze Entwicklung ja mega rasant und weiß gar nicht, bei wie viel tausend wir jetzt mittlerweile angekommen sind.
Mehr als 4tausend haben.
4000 genau so und wer durchaus jetzt auch noch damit zu rechnen, dass diese Zahl noch weiter vielleicht sogar exponentiell ansteigt. Ja und diese.
Visionen, dass man eben vielleicht wirklich,
mahlenden Planeten auch wirklich sehen kann, also außerhalb unseres Sonnensystems, wäre ja auch ganz interessant auch für unser Sonnensystem, so mit Planet Nine, also dieser Vermutung
ob sie nicht vielleicht noch einen neunten Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem gibt. Weiß nicht, wie da gerade so die Wahrscheinlichkeiten verteilt sind, aber.
Auch noch was dazu sagen, ja.
Ja machen wir das doch mal, weil das ist ja im Prinzip auch so ein ähnliches Problem, so dieser diese Blick ins Dunkle, ne, also vielleicht zum Hintergrund, dieser nein, das war ja quasi so eine so eine These.
Das das Pluto-Killers, wie heißt das.
Mike Brown, Mike.
Mike Brown, genau, der sozusagen ja dafür verantwortlich war, dass Pluto seinen Planetenstatus aber keine bekommen hat, so hat ja diese ganzen äh
tunischen Objekte beobachtet und festgestellt, dass es alles irgendwie so ein bisschen so zu einer Seite verklumpt und das normalerweise will ja immer alles gleichmäßig,
verteilt sein und die Vermutung ja geäußert hat mit seinem Team ist ja eben so okay, alles klar, kann sein, dass wir halt noch einen
neuen Planeten haben, der wirklich verdammt weit draußen ist und deswegen ja auch für uns eben so nicht sichtbar ist, weil wir auch nicht wissen, wo er ist und gerade, wenn er eben, also angenommen es gäbe ihn,
und er würde sich aber gerade in seinem.
Orbild, der viele hundert Jahre dauert, gerade so direkt auch vor so unserer Galaxiescheibe bewegen, dann haben wir ja auch wieder dieses Problem, dass wir den gar nicht von dem restlichen Kram, den man sieht, so ohne weiteres trennen konnte.
Kann es sein, dass hier ein Teleskop auch schon wieder Kenntnisse liefert.
Da gibt's sogar noch eine zusätzliche, interessante Spekulation, nämlich wir haben ja jetzt versucht, so gut wie möglich zu schauen, wo der Planet sein könnte und bisher wurde noch nichts entdeckt,
Die Hoffnung ist, dass dann zum Beispiel, wenn das,
mal angeschaltet wird, dass die noch viel empfindlicher noch größere Flächen abdecken können, dass man ihn vielleicht doch sieht. Aber ein Forscher hat jetzt die Idee rausgebracht, ob es sich dabei nicht vielleicht sogar um ein schwarzes Loch handeln könnte,
wenn wenn schwarze Löcher primorteal sind, dann gehen wir davon aus, dass es auch Planet schwarze Löcher geben könnte.
Und dann könnte also jedes, jedes Sonnensystem auch noch ein schwarzes Loch als Planet haben. Und dieser Planet neun.
Möglicherweise so ein schwarzes Loch sein, das wäre dann nur Tennisball groß, ähm,
Aber ungefähr so schwer wie vier, vier Erdenmassen. Also das wäre das ist natürlich extrem spannend. dummerweise gab's jetzt eine Publikation vor kurzem,
behauptet haben, dass das ein reiner Auswahleffekt ist, dass also dass die Tatsache, dass diese transneptonischen Planeten waren, Zwergplaneten waren, die alle so geklumpt sind,
Dass es einfach reiner Zufall war, weil die nur in die eine Richtung geschaut haben und die, die haben also ähnliche Untersuchungen in anderen Richtungen gemacht und finden praktisch ähnliche Verklumpungen auch in andere Richtungen sozusagen. Und.
Dann wäre das Spaß vorbei, aber.
Brown und Konstantin Bad Tigin, die beiden Vertreter kämpfen nach wie vor, also wie Löwen um die Existenz dieses Planeten neun, also es das bleibt spannend.
Vielleicht noch eine Sache, wir haben an einem anderen Sonnensystem, hat vor kurzem,
so ein Planet neun tatsächlich gesehen, also da konnte man ein Bild davon machen, von einem Planeten, das war ein Doppel-Sternsystem und es gibt einen Planeten, der so weit draußen ist, wie ungefähr unser Planet neun sein sollte, also das ist nicht ganz aus der Welt, dass es euch,
solche weit entfernten Planeten.
Es kann halt sein, aber man weiß es noch nicht. Aber die äh,
Aber steht natürlich hier nicht im Fokus, sondern man will jetzt, das haben wir ja im Prinzip auch schon angesprochen, Exkurneten eben genauer untersuchen und eben vielleicht sogar auch sehen und dann natürlich dann auch vielleicht
auch nochmal ganz neu durchleuchten, um mehr darüber zu erfahren, wie die zusammengesetzt sind. Und damit endlich mal unsere zweite Erde äh.
Ja ja, genau.
Gar nicht, was seine ersten so schlecht ist, dass man sich so sehr auf die zweite freut.
Also ja ganz spannend sind halt Planeten, die sich in der sogenannten Havitablenzone bewegen, also wo das Wasser,
möglicherweise flüssig ist. Wir nennen die auch temperierte Exemplane, also die sind weder zu kalt noch zu warm, also sie haben halt schön gemütliche Temperatur.
jetzt ist es so, wenn man wirklich einen Sonnenähnlichen Stern hat und man möchte einen erdähnlichen Planeten um diesen Sonnenährlichen Stern sehen,
dann weiß man, dass dieser Planet ungefähr eine astronomische Einheit von seinem Stern entfernt sein sollte und dann würde ein Jahr in diesem Planeten auch ungefähr ein Jahr dauern.
Und alle, alle Entdeckungsmöglichkeiten sind ja auf die abgehoben, also ob das jetzt die Radialgeschwindigkeit zur Bewegung ist, also dieser sogenannte,
oder ob das diese Transe sind. Man muss um einen wirklich erdähnlichen Planeten zu sehen, muss man mindestens drei Jahre beobachten, kontinuierlich in die gleiche Richtung,
um eine Erde zu sehen. Das haben wir bisher noch nie gemacht. Also wir hatten überhaupt noch keine Gelegenheit, eine zweite Erde zu finden.
Erste, der das vermutlich machen könnte, wäre Plato, die diese diese neue Planetenjäger, den die Isar im Moment baut.
Quasi so ein Käppler-Nachfolger.
Ja genau, das ist ein Nachfolger. Der 26 Teleskope hat und gleichzeitig aus allen Rohren sozusagen auf den Himmel schießt.
Sich dieses okay.
Und und deswegen insbesondere die die nahen Planeten Entschuldigung, die nahen Sterne relativ gut beobachten kann und da haben wir tatsächlich die Hoffnung.
Plato irgendwann mal einen wirklich erdähnlichen Planeten gefunden haben finden könnte.
Was wir bereits kennen, sind erdähnliche Planeten, also in in temperierten Zonen, um rote Zwerge. also nicht um sonnenähnliche Sterne, aber um rote Zwergsterne.
Weil da ist es so, dass die.
Wesentlich weniger hell und dort ist die habitable Zone relativ nah an dem Stern. Und da braucht man nur ein paar Wochen beobachten, um so einen Stern zu sehen,
von denen haben wir schon eine ganze Reihe gefunden das ist eben zum Beispiel dieses Trapez eins System,
aber hat jetzt auch ein ähnliches System gefunden,
unter einem Namen T O I eins sieben acht oder irgendwie sowas? Das sind also,
Exemplaten, die felsig sind. Wir wissen, dass sie so ähnlich wie die Erde sind und sie sind, wir finden sich in einer Umlaufbahn um ihren Stern
wo das Wasser durchaus flüssig sein könnte. Und solche Systeme werden natürlich jetzt insbesondere von James Web auch beobachtet.
Aber man muss dazu sagen, diese roten Zwergsterne, das sind irgendwie ungemütliche Gesellen, die,
wir wissen ja, dass die Sonne auch manchmal Flairs aussendet und Sonnenwind und magnetische Stürme und so weiter. Diese roten Zwergsterne haben oft hundert bis tausendmal mehr Aktivität als als die Sonne,
die würden praktisch ihre ganzen Planeten irgendwie rönken oder durch Strahlen und so weiter. Also die wir gehen davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich um rote Zwergsterne kein
Leben geben kann, weil das Leben vermutlich durch die Strahlung irgendwie stark beeinflusst wird.
Ich sehe schon, wir müssen uns doch noch mit unserer Erde arrangieren.
Natürlich, also wir haben im Moment keinen Planet B, aber, wie gesagt, also James Web wird auf jeden Fall die einzelnen, sagen wir mal, goldenen Tages, die wir heute haben, die besten,
zu Tode beobachten. die Isa baut ja im Moment auch einen Satelliten Ariel, der.
Spektroskopieuntersuchung an ungefähr tausend Planeten machen will. Also wir wollen das ganze Feld der der,
chemischen Analyse von Planetenatmosphären aufrollen
James Rap wird sich auf einzelne Fälle konzentrieren und die also wirklich ganz besonders detailliert studieren, während Ariel dann praktisch so den ganzen Feldwald und Wiesen Zweig abdeckt
Und die Hoffnung ist, dass irgendwo zwischen James Web und Ariel Complato und hoffentlich entdecken wir dann auch noch den richtigen
Wir wollen nicht nur eine Erde entdecken, sondern vielleicht eine Handvoll oder sowas oder zehn Stück.
Und das wird diese Tage jetzt dann auch das James Web lange genug lebt, dass wir die dann auch alle noch im detailliert studieren.
Ja, dann weiß ich, zum zur Erforschung des Sonnensystems haben wir ja jetzt schon was gesagt, also die Planeten nochmal neu anzuschauen. Gibt's da noch weitere Dinge.
Nein, also nur, dass halt sozusagen das das Sonnensystem selber uns natürlich auch immer wieder vor neue Entdeckungen stellt. Also wir wir hatten vorher gerade von diesen ähm,
interstellaten Besuchern gesprochen. Es gibt inzwischen einen zweiten Interstellarenbesucher, den hat auch Happel sehr genau beobachtet, das war tatsächlich ein Komet, also dort kam ein,
Objekt von einem anderen Sternsystem, was praktisch dann auch einen wirklichen Kometenschweif erzeugt hat,
und man hat anhand des Schweiß mit Radiobeobachtungen dann festgestellt, dass dieser Komet selbst sein eigenes Sonnensystem, seine eigene Sonne noch nie besucht hat. Das heißt also, er wurde aus der
Ort, Wolke seines eigenen Sonnensystems rausgekickt und Richtung unserem Sonnensystem geschickt, bevor er seine eigene Sonnige gesehen hat.
Und diese sogenannten Prestinen, also ganz frischen Kometen. sind unheimlich interessant. Ähm,
weil die sozusagen das noch klarste Abbild der früh, also das das Sonnensystems, bevor die Sonne überhaupt entstanden ist, also die Materie, die die enthalten ist, noch nicht prozessiert worden durch die Sonne selbst.
Durch zahlreiche Sonnenbesuche, ja.
Ja, genau. Und deswegen sind sogenannte Prestinikometen ganz besonders interessant.
Und wir haben ja sogar jetzt einen, eine eigene Mission entwickelt. Comic Intercep.
Die zum Ziel hat, einen solchen Kometen dann, wenn er mal entdeckt wird, auch direkt zu besuchen, also das der wird,
Zusammen mit Ariel wird diese Mission gestartet, wird dann,
Auch an dem Lavance Punkt zwei sich aufhalten und wartet dann, bis wir den richtigen Kometen entdeckt haben, um dann dorthin.
So ein Weltraumschläfer.
Ja, genau, ein Weltraumschläfer, sicher. Richtig.
Und da würde ich mir erhoffen, also wenn das, wenn die Theorie stimmt, dann sollten wir alle paar Jahre wieder ein interstellares Objekt,
decken. Ähm,
die sind also jetzt innerhalb von zwei, drei Jahren haben wir schon zwei entdeckt, also können wir davon ausgehen, dass da noch mehr kommen. Und so ähnlich wie Happeln natürlich jetzt, ganz intensiv eingesetzt wird, um die zu studieren, wird natürlich James Web genauso verwendet werden.
James Map wird dann vielleicht auch eine wichtige Rolle spielen in der Auswahl des Tages, was wir dann mit dem ansteuern wollen.
Sind das so wahrscheinlich, dass man über die Laufzeit des Schläfers dann auch wirklich was findet, was was man dann anfahren will.
Also es ist nicht, es muss nicht nur ein,
Es müsste dich unbedingt ein interstellares Objekt sein, es könnte auch ein Komet aus unserer eigenen Ortwolke sein, der aber vorher noch nie da war. Also nicht der Halley oder wie heißt der, Yakutake oder sowas, sondern ein komplett frischer,
Komet.
Und um überhaupt dessen Frischheit sozusagen, also wenn mal ein Komet entdeckt wird und dann sagen zu können, dass er ein frischer Komitismus von ihn ja beobachten und da wird James Web dann auch eine Rolle spielen.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht null, die ist so also in der Gegend von eins, dass in einer Laufzeit von drei Jahren waren so ein Objekt entdeckt, wo der dann auch hinfahren kann.
Also man sieht schon.
Schon jetzt ist das Spektrum im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, was man mit James Rap ab decken kann, relativ groß.
Das sind jetzt so quasi so unsere das sind so die Dinge, von denen man weiß, dass man sie nicht weiß, wie viel Potenzial für uns hat man denn hier vielleicht noch mit dem Projekt?
Na ja, anderen sind natürlich immer sehr sehr schwer vorher zu sagen, aber wenn man aus der Vergangenheit schaut, wie das bei war, dann,
glaube ich, dass die anderen so ungefähr fünfmal mehr sind als die sozusagen. Das heißt also, man wird, man wird sehr, sehr viel sogenannte,
also zufällig Entdeckung machen. Vielleicht noch ein ganz spannendes Gebiet, was mehr so ein Know-Un ist, ähm,
diese Gravitationswellen Vereinigungen also vor allem wenn sich zwei Neutronensterne miteinander vereinigen,
das haben wir ja bisher erst ein einziges Mal gesehen vor einigen Jahren, also es Gravitationswellen von 200 Tonnen Sternen gab, die explodiert sind, also nicht explodiert, aber die ähm,
eine ein Signal gegeben haben. Dann gab's ein Gamma Strahlen Blitz dazu, der wenige Sekunden später angetroffen ist.
Und dann hat man hinterher mit allen Teleskopen der Welt geschaut und hat tatsächlich festgestellt, dass es dort eine Explosionswolke gab, also eine sogenannte Killonova, äh,
kleines schwaches, aber sehr interessantes Signal am Himmel. Und wenn so was wieder passiert, dann wird natürlich James Web, also praktisch das Gebot der Stunde sein, also weil das,
diese Kilonove, die haben auch insbesondere im Infraroten Bereich strahlen die ihr Spektrum ab und da ähm.
Signal, was wir schon wissen, von dieser ersten Kilo Nova ist, dass,
die schweren Elemente so wie zum Beispiel Uran oder Gold oder Platin oder selbst Jod also alles so auch was in unserem Körper ist, dass die schweren Elemente durch die Vereinigung von Neutronenstern entstehen.
Ohne Kilo Nova kein Mensch.
Genau und es ist ja so, wir wir wissen ja schon, dass wir Sternenstaub sind, wir wissen auch, dass der ganze Wasserstoff in unserem Körper eigentlich direkt im Urknall entstanden sind. Aber wir wissen jetzt auch,
Neutronensternstaub sind. Und und wie gesagt, ja, ohne das kein Mensch.
Und tatsächlich hat sich seitdem nie wieder so ein richtig gutes Ereignis gezeigt.
Und im in der Laufzeit von James Web hoffen wir natürlich, dass auch die nächste Generation von Generations von von Gravitationswellen der Detektoren existiert, auch Leige und äh,
und so weiter werden empfindlicher werden.
Lisa kommt noch dazu im All.
Dann kommt Lisa, wobei im Moment Lisa so zwanzig, sechsunddreißig ungefähr startet, dann bin ich nicht sicher, dass James Web da noch existiert.
Ja
Okay, verstehe. Aber das ist im Prinzip ja die Perspektive der Multimessenger, Astronomie, dass man einfach jetzt verschiedene Messsysteme auch miteinander kombiniert. Das ist hier auch schon zahlreich dokumentiert worden bei Raumzeit, dass wir jetzt einfach,
zusätzlich zu der Beobachtung des Elektromagnetismus im All einfach über Gravitationswellen, über Neutrinos.
So ein armes Ding, ja.
Einfach neue ja andere Brillen bekommen, mit denen wir ins All schauen können und die sich das eben dann auch ja zeitschnell
miteinander kombinieren lässt, nicht wahr als Beispiel mit der mit dem Empfang der Gravitationswelle von dem Neutronenstern. Man wusste dann einfach, aha, okay, alles klar, alle mal höher hören,
da schauen wir jetzt mal hin, was ja auch schon grob verortet werden konnte. Man wusste zumindest in etwa, wo man hinschauen musste und dann konnte dieser Blitz empfangen werden, was ja dann im Prinzip auch der Beleg war für.
Etwas, was man schon lange vermutet hat, aber soeben noch nie hat messen können, dass man einfach sagte, okay, diese Blitze, das
sind dann eben auch die Auswirkungen der Vereinigung zweier Neutronensterne und jetzt haben wir das dann auch mal in die Bücher geschrieben,
So was wäre natürlich dann hier auch ja eine neue Qualität äh.
Ja, also beziehungsweise man kann so sagen, ähm,
diese erste Entdeckung ist im Übrigen im Jahr, in dem das Periodensystem der Elemente 100 Jahre alt wurde, gemacht worden und das
Periodensystem der Elemente wurde in dem Jahr umgeschrieben. Also man kann zu jedem Element jetzt hinschreiben, ist es aus einem Neudronenstein entstanden
oder ist es aus einer Supernova Explosion entstanden.
Aber die Messungen selber waren immer noch ziemlich, sagen wir mal, rudimentär, man hat.
Ganz, ganz wenige von diesen Elementen wirklich spektroskopisch nachweisen können, sondern das passiert alles immer noch auf Modellen sozusagen. Und wenn es wirklich mal gelänge, so eine Kilonova-Explosion, dann,
zu analysieren und dann tatsächlich die chemischen Fingerabdrücke der Elemente dort zu sehen, dann ist es sozusagen nochmal eine Bestätigung, was bisher noch ein bisschen reines Modell ist.
Ja das ist ja ein toller Ausblick. Jetzt ähm.
Natürlich nur hoffen, dass der Staat gelingt, dass die Inbetriebnahme funktioniert und all diese ganzen potenziellen Erkenntnisse auch wirklich eingesammelt werden können.
Gehen wir einfach mal vom Besten aus. Jetzt bleibt ja die Entwicklung an der Stelle auch nicht stehen und es gibt ja sicherlich auch schon
neue Ideen, was man sich denn sonst noch mal so alles anschauen könnte, was ist was zeichnet sich denn ab in diesem Weltraum Teleskop Bereich, wo will man noch auf welche Art und Weise hinschauen.
Also wir hatten ja vorher schon drüber gesprochen, wie strategisch sich sozusagen die verschiedenen Weltraumorganisationen aufstellen und wie die ESA zum Beispiel als Juniorpartner bei den amerikanischen,
Strategie, Mission mitmacht und umgekehrt die Nase auch bei uns mitmacht.
Als nächste große Mission, die jetzt bereits schon in Planung sind und
auch jetzt relativ bald mit dem Bau beginnt. ist auf der Seite gibt es Assina, das ist sozusagen das nächste große Röntgenteleskop, was nach dem und kommt.
Und da ist tatsächlich die Nase als Juniorpartner beteiligt dran. Das ist also ein ein riesen Teleskop und dann eben Lisa, von dem wir schon gesprochen haben, was wo auch die NASA an einem beteiligt ist.
Gleichzeitig macht die NASA oder überhaupt die amerikanische Akademie der Wissenschaften alle zehn Jahre in die Servie und stellen sozusagen die Prioritäten für die nächsten zehn Jahre ähm,
ins Licht,
Und da sind sie im Moment, also alle warten praktisch gespannt in den nächsten paar Wochen soll die Empfehlung rauskommen, was jetzt das nächste große.
Nach James Web, beziehungsweise nach James Web kommt noch das Nancy Grace Roman ähm,
Teleskop, das ist also so ein.
So groß wie Hable etwa, aber mit viel größerem Gesichtsfeld, was also zusammen mit mit und anderen auch die dunkle Energie studieren soll. Das das ist sozusagen schon ähm.
Im Bau. Aber was danach kommt, da diskutiert die ähm
Akademie der Wissenschaften im Moment grade drüber, beziehungsweise haben sie sich wahrscheinlich schon geeinigt, aber wir wissen's noch nicht. Und in den Wettbewerb sind vier Ideen eingegangen, also vier nächste mögliche Großteilesgruppe
eins davon ist das größte und wahrscheinlich auch komplizierteste ist dass,
Das ist so die eierlegende Wollmilchsau von allen. Und das soll ein,
in so einem Konzept her soll das ungefähr den doppelt so großen Spiegel haben wie James Web, also zwölf Meter. Das wäre quasi in der.
Genealogie von Huble, James Web, wer das der nächste große Schritt.
Ist aber natürlich auch nicht billig und, und, und hat vermutlich ähnliche Herausforderungen wie James Web hatte. eine kleinere Variante von ist das sogenannte Harp Excelliscoup. Das sucht nach,
das ist mehr von der 6 Meter Klasse aber auch also praktischen James Web Nachfolger.
Und dann gibt es ein Konzept, das nennt sich Origin Stales Group, das möchte im fernen Infraroten beobachten, also da wo herrschel, schon beobachtet hat,
das soll also ein gekühltes sein.
Und ein vierter Kandidat war das sogenannte Links-Teneskop, das ist ein Branken,
Teleskop in Nachfolge von Tantra. was also praktisch mit noch schärferen Augen und noch größerem Spiegel als Sandra funktionieren möchte,
und was genau rauskommt, kann man natürlich jetzt noch nicht sagen, werde ich im Moment mich auch zurückhalten,
Persönlich glaube ich, dass es vermutlich so eine Art Mischung zwischen dem Luis und dem Harburgs, also glaube ich, ein bisschen zu kompliziert äh, aber dass irgendwas in der Richtung rauskommt.
Aber es bleibt spannend.
Und es ist vor allem klar, Weltraum Teleskope, das ist auf jeden Fall
nach wie vor ein großes Ding in der Raumfahrt, das wird auf jeden Fall stattfinden beziehungsweise in der Gastronomie, weil da ist einfach noch der größte Fragenkatalog offen
und in allen nur erdenklichen Frequenzbereichen. Also man will einfach am liebsten überall hinschauen, die ganze Zeit und soweit wie möglich. Ist ja klar. ich frage mich, ob's dann überhaupt noch genug Wissenschaftler gibt.
Papers zu schreiben, weil es ja einfach viel zu.
lassen sie mich vielleicht noch eins sagen, die Esa hat ihrerseits jetzt auch wir machen keine Zehnjahresplanung, sondern wir machen so eine zwanzig, Fünfundzwanzig-Jahres-Planung,
befinden uns im Moment in dem Zeitalter des heißt also das sind die großen Missionen so wie,
zum Jupiter, den wir nächstes Jahr starten, Lisa und Asina.
wir haben jetzt grade eine neue strategische Planung aufgelegt für die nächsten zehn, fünfundzwanzig Jahre. die heißt voyage twenty-fifty, also die Reise nach zwanzig fünfzig.
Und im Rahmen dieses haben wir schon die drei großen Themen,
die drei großen L-Klasse-Missionen nach Lisa festgelegt.
Das erste Thema ist dass wir zu dem zu den Monden.
Großen Planeten, also entweder Jupiter, Saturn oder sogar Neptun Oranus, diese Mode genauer ins Blick in den Blick nehmen. Da gibt es ja sogenannte Ozeanwelten, wo möglicherweise Wasser und vielleicht sogar Leben existiert.
Enzilados, unsere.
Das genau.
Sachen, ja, unbedingt bitte.
Ich träume davon, ob wir nicht vielleicht auf Entseler das landen können und einen Eiskern erboren und wieder zurückblicken könnten. das ist aber noch also das geht im Moment noch über unsere Möglichkeiten hinaus, aber vielleicht,
kriegen wir das ja hin, dass wir dir unsere Möglichkeiten verbessern. der zweite, das zweite Thema ist ein spannendes Thema, das hängt auch mit Exo-Planeten zusammen,
da wollen wir untersuchen, ob es tatsächlich möglich ist, von so einem temperierten Exemplaten ein Bild oder ein Spektrum zu machen. Also wenn wir mal eine zweite Erde hätten.
Braucht man ein Interpyrometer oder irgendeine Struktur, mit der man in der Lage ist, den genau anzuschauen. Das ist also ein Thema. Und ein zweites Thema in dem ähnlichen Zusammenhang ist, dass wir uns überlegen, ob wir nicht ein.
Geyer im Infraroten,
bauen. Also genau wie ich James Web ins Infrarot geht, könnten wir die Astrometrie auch im Infraroten machen. Dann würden wir in das galaktische Zentrum reinschauen können und in die ganzen Sternenstehungsgebiete uns.
Stimmt, das hat Geier noch gar nicht abgedeckt. Also im Prinzip auf dem selben Funktionsprinzip auch.
Arbeit mit Astrometrie und nicht mit mit großem,
Bildmaterial. Und das dritte ist auch extrem spannend und zwar wollen wir,
Die dritte Mission dem frühen Universum widmen, wollen irgendwas machen, womit wir vielleicht die Inflationsphase des Urknalls messen können.
Das wäre also entweder ein extrem präzises Mikrowellenhintergrund Projekt, so ähnlich wie blank, aber mit spektroskopie und.
Oder ein Nachfolger von Lisa, ein Teleskop, was nochmal in einem anderen Frequenzbereich noch noch genauer misst.
Wo wir gerne vielleicht die die das Urknall Echo, also das Gravitationsecho des sehen wollen.
Also die Themen gehen uns nicht aus. Es bleibt spannend und wir haben also die nächsten 50 Jahre auch schon fest im Griff.
Das freut mich sehr. Ich hatte schon Angst, hier keine Themen mehr für meinen Podcast zu haben.
Nachgestellte Frage, wir haben jetzt viel über Isa und NASA und die Kanadier gesprochen hier und da sind ja auch die
Japaner mit dabei, speziell was jetzt so Astriden Asteroiden Mission betrifft, das ist ja so ein Spezialisierungsfeld, was ich immer selten höre, ist China. Jetzt ist ja Esa eigentlich schon noch
gefühlt, glaube ich, der einzige, der überhaupt mit den Chinesen zusammen was macht,
Die Fähigkeiten der Chinesen haben sich ja nun auch dramatisch verbessert. Ähm,
sind das absehbar, dass diese ganzen internationalen Missionen dann auch in irgendeiner Form mal mit China stattfinden.
Also vielleicht nochmal kurz zurück zu Japan. Japan ist tatsächlich auch nach Nase einer unserer wirklich wichtigsten und wird vertrauenswürdigsten Kooperationspartner.
Auf der ISS.
ISS, aber auch wir zum Beispiel Bepic Colombo haben wir gestartet, da ist ein japanisches Satellit dabei zum zum Merkur.
Wir sind unsererseits an dieser,
japanischen Maß Mission MMX beteiligt, wo man vom Fokus Material zurückholen möchte. Das wird auch bald gestartet
und Japan ist auch bei Asina, also in dem Teleskop mit beschäftigt. Also Japan ist wirklich einer unserer wirklich wichtigsten Kooperationspartner. Gleichzeitig hat die ISA tatsächlich mit China schon sehr lange
sehr konstruktive Zusammenarbeit das ging schon los vor 20 Jahren oder 15 Jahren mit Double Star ähm,
und wir wir sind im Moment dabei, was einzigartig ist, ein gemeinsames China-ESA-Projekt, das ist heißt smile.
Das ist ein fifty-fifty Projekt, wo die und China ungefähr gleichviel,
und was tatsächlich in einem der sagen wir mal Prozess in einem demokratischen Verfahren entstanden ist und wir die Chinesen sind also sehr.
Darauf bedacht sozusagen auch von uns zu lernen, wie man die wissenschaftliche Community einbindet für für die Zukunft. Das ist auch ein Teil des ähm
wo wir uns das Geben sonst nehmen und die Chinesen haben auch einen Röntgenprojekt, das heißt Einstein Prop.
Wo wir bereits Spiegel geliefert haben.
Es gibt doch dieses Aerosita Projekt, an dem ich ursprünglich beteiligt war, was ein russisch-deutsches Gemeinschaftsprojekt ist, wo die.
Einer von denen wurde jetzt nach China.
Geliefert. Das heißt also, wir sind tatsächlich mit den Chinesen auch auf Hardwarebene in Zusammenarbeit. Wir sehen, wie die dramatisch sich entwickeln und wie sie Dinge können, die sie.
Also wenn man mit Chinesen redet und sagt, man braucht Geduld im Weltraum, dann sagen sie, wir haben in,
20 Jahren unser ganzes Land umgestellt. Warum kann man nicht eine Weltraummission fahren, die schneller geht. Und das machen die auch.
Was die Chinesen umgekehrt aber in im privaten Gespräch auch sagen, ist, dass wenn es darum geht,
komplett neue Technologie von der Pike auf zu entwickeln, so wie zum Beispiel Lisa Pastfinder oder die ganzen Gravitationswellen Geschichten.
Das können sie noch nicht so gut. sie sie können extrem gut Dinge aufgreifen, kopieren, besser machen, die es schon gibt. Aber komplett neue Technologien zu entwickeln. Da sind sie noch ein Schritt weiter hinten.
Und ich glaube, das ist für uns wichtig, also wenn wir im Wettbewerb, also ein entweder im freundschaftlichen Wettbewerb oder auch sagen wir mal, nicht so freundschaftlichen, ökonomischen Wettbewerbe mit den Chinesen.
Vorn behalten wollen, dann müssen wir sehr, sehr viel investieren in neue Technologien und es hat also keinen Sinn,
die Flut aufzuhalten, die die sozusagen hinten drankommt, sondern man muss immer einen Schritt weiter vorne sein.
Ja, da scheint's noch eine Menge Potential zu geben. Herr Hasinger, vielen vielen Dank für die Ausführung zum James Webtelskop und all den anderen Themen, die da noch so mit dranhängen.
Vielen Dank Herr Friedlow. Es war eine große Freude.
Genau, jetzt hoffen wir mal alle, dass der Staat dann gelingt im Dezember und sowohl die Ariane als auch die sonstige.
Wunderbar funktioniert und dann.
Eigentlich auch schon auf die neuen Erkenntnissen, die dann über uns ergossen wird. Dass da eine ganze Menge Potenzial ist, das haben wir jetzt.
War's. Ich sag tschüss und bis bald.